Ich bräuchte mal ganz dringend einen Firefox-Engineer.
Du bist ein Firefox-Engineer im Wesen.
Geht das mit Firefox oder soll ich lieber den Chromium nehmen?
Ich bin ein Firefox auf jeden Fall.
Ich werde mir keinen Chrome installieren.
Also, ich würde gerne mein Mikro nicht mit Work Adventure sharen.
Ich möchte aber beides.
Kann ich da...
Prinzipiell geht es, dass du einfach beides
im gleichen Browser aufmachst.
Du kannst dich einfach in WorkAdventure muten.
Welchen WorkAdventure
seid ihr denn?
In deinem.
Im Rust?
Ja, im Rust. Wir sind bloß rausgegangen
von der Bar weg
zurück auf den großen Teppich, damit wir uns auch sehen können.
Wo ist denn der große Teppich?
Also ich sehe da
den Simulator.
Ah, der Teppich.
Okay.
Ich kann im Zweifel ja auch einfach
den Tab an sich muten.
Dann werde ich auf jeden Fall keinen hören.
Ah, gute Idee.
Sehr clever.
Ich sag dir doch, es ist gut, wenn man einen
Fireworks-Ingenieur hat.
Wofür haben wir das denn alles eingebaut?
Ich hab ein bisschen den Überblick verloren,
aber ich glaube, ich mach alles richtig.
Wir Zencaster machen das einfach.
Wir nehmen das.
Ja, es muss einfach funktionieren.
Ich mach nochmal kurz 3, 2, 1.
Hi Kilian.
Hey Stefan.
Hey Jan-Erik.
Hey Florian.
Hi alle.
So, das ist akronomisierbar Folge 45.
Schön, dass ihr alle dabei seid.
Das ist unsere alljährliche Sonderfolge zum Kongress.
ich sehe, ihr seid alle nicht auf dem
Kongress. Was ist los?
Wir sind doch alle da. Wir stehen alle auf demselben
Lina-Teppich.
Ach stimmt.
Rast Assembly hat.
Ich habe mich ja nur reingeschlichen.
Hier irgendwie so.
Das ist ja nicht mal der offizielle Server.
Das ist ja hier der Zweit-Server quasi.
Der offizielle, offizielle.
Genau. Also, was ist los?
Wir haben 2020 und 2020
ist natürlich alles anders und
nichts funktioniert, wie wir das eigentlich
19 kannten. Und auch
der Kongress ist, also der Kongress ist
eigentlich nicht wirklich so, wie er ist normalerweise.
Und wir haben uns jetzt alle auf dem inoffiziellen
Work Adventure der
Rastations getroffen, stehen jetzt hier
gemeinsam auf dem WLAN-Teppich
und können uns im Jitsi zuwinken.
Und jeder sitzt bei sich in seinem respektiven
Wohnzimmer oder Küche
oder Schlafzimmer und so weiter und so fort.
Und
wir dachten uns, diese Folge,
dadurch, dass das nur alles ein bisschen anders
funktioniert dieses Jahr, können wir eigentlich auch direkt darüber
reden. 2020 ist vorbei.
Congress ist anders.
Und Konferenzen allgemein 2020
funktionieren auch anders.
Deswegen dachten wir uns, machen wir mal eine Folge,
wo wir genau darüber reden, wie funktioniert so ein
Zeug jetzt eigentlich dieses Jahr,
wo es sich kein,
wo man nicht viele Leute in einen Raum
packen kann, ohne dass
man gleich Leben dabei gefährdet.
Und dafür haben
wir uns ganz besondere Gäste dieses Mal eingeladen.
Und ihr habt den Namen gerade
eben schon gehört. Ich möchte nochmal der Reihe
vorstellen. Ich freue mich zu begrüßen.
Florian Kircher
war bereits einmal bei uns zu Gast
und hat dieses Thema vorgeschlagen.
Dann haben wir Jan-Erik.
Jan-Erik, grüß dich.
Mitorganisator des RustFest.
Eigentlich trifft diese Aussage auf alle zu.
Und dann haben wir noch den Stefan,
DNS zu U2F8.
Schön, dass ihr alle da seid.
Hallo.
Die Aussage trifft nicht auf alle zu.
ich organisiere das erst fest nicht mehr mit.
Ich habe mich da zurückgezogen.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Genau, dann muss ich das gleich wieder redigieren.
So, wie läuft denn das jetzt für euch so ab?
Ihr habt dieses Jahr an Konferenzen nicht nur teilgenommen,
sondern auch mit selbst organisiert.
Aber vielleicht können wir mal kurz irgendwie in das Thema einsteigen.
Auf was für Konferenzen warten ihr so dieses Jahr?
Online oder nicht?
Das Jahr ist ziemlich lang, das gefühlt schon, keine Ahnung, diese Feuer in Australien, dass das dieses Jahr war, das habe ich ja auch schon wieder komplett an den Tisch fallen lassen und was an dem so passiert ist.
Ich musste tatsächlich kurz drüber nachdenken.
Ich habe tatsächlich sogar einen Vortrag gehalten auf einer Konferenz dieses Jahr.
Aber ansonsten hat es mich tatsächlich bislang nur zu Russ-Konferenzen dieses Jahr getrieben.
Und so ein, zwei Nicht-Russ-Konferenzen habe ich am Seitenrand mitgenommen,
einfach um zu gucken, wie machen die es denn?
Ja, bei mir war der Anfang vom Jahr noch ganz gut mit so Sport.
nicht so Konferenzen,
aber dann
ab März
war dann ziemlich Sense.
Und dann im Sommer wieder.
Im Sommer war wieder ganz gut.
Da gab es eine Akro-Convention nochmal.
Also für die, die es nicht wissen,
Akrobatik ist das, wo man
im Zirkus mit Menschen jongliert.
Sehr gutes Workout.
Die machen das.
Mit Menschen jonglieren ist ein gutes Workout.
Das ist eine schöne Aussage.
Stimmt auch.
Wo man sich gegenseitig kunstvoll hochhebt.
Ein bisschen weniger dramatisch.
Cool.
Die haben bei uns beim Unisport
immer in der gleichen Halle trainiert,
wo ich meinen Jonglierkurs hatte.
Das war immer sehr schön an der Ferne anzugucken.
Aber ja, sonst
Rastfest
und jetzt RC3.
Genau, habt ihr euch Vorträge
vom Kongress bislang angeguckt?
Also ich bin im Kongress
genauso aktiv wie die Jahre zuvor.
Ich glaube, ich habe bislang
insgesamt 10 Minuten Vortrag gesehen
und 5 Mate getrunken.
So muss das.
Das Verhältnis kommt grob hin.
Ein Vortrag, den ich
tatsächlich empfehlen kann, ist der
How to Hack the German Elections. Den hatte ich
an Tag 1 noch mitgenommen. Ich glaube, das war auch
einer von zwei Talks, die ich bisher geschaut habe.
Ich habe nicht
erwartet, dass die da...
Man erwartet, dass die Wahlsoftware
ein bisschen anzeigen.
Wie man ja nicht weiß, ist das in Deutschland
sehr wohl Wahlsoftware genutzt wird
zur Auszählung der Stimmen, nicht zum tatsächlichen Abstimmen,
aber zur Auszählung.
Und ich dachte, die packen da irgendwelche
krassen Exploiter, um es kaputt zu machen.
Turns out, die Software ist so shitty,
du brauchst da halt nicht mal irgendwelche Exploiter auspacken.
Zum Beispiel, da hast du ein Admin-Panel
und das validiert nicht mal, ob dein Nutzer
irgendwelche angelockten Admin-Rechte hat,
sondern du gehst da einfach auf die URL, kannst
Cross-Site Request Forgery machen, weil die natürlich auch
irgendwelche Rechner nutzen in irgendwelchen
Grundschulen, die auch im Netz hängen
und kannst da hier sonst was für Scheiße
machen, um die Stimme im Hintergrund zu fälschen.
Das ist super easy. Du musst da
literally nichts an
Xbox für auspacken. Das ist echt
erschreckend, aber war ein toller Vortrag.
War gut gemacht. Erschreckend und unterhaltsam
zugleich.
Muss ich mir vielleicht mal noch anschauen.
Ich habe
das Jahr angefangen
erstmal mit
eine Monat Krankheit.
Fand ich sehr gut.
So kurz vor der Pandemie.
Und dann
habe ich
organisiert die Oxidize-Conf
im Juni und die
war natürlich genauso in der Ecke.
So, na, kommen wir über die erste Welle noch drüber.
Kann man vielleicht, so gucken wir mal, wie es läuft und so weiter.
Aber die haben die da noch
abgesagt. Ich muss auch sagen,
der Veranstaltungsort,
mit dem ich da unterwegs war,
die waren da sehr, sehr gut und sehr, sehr freundlich.
Haben gesagt, ihr könnt es canceln, ihr könnt es verschieben,
wenn ihr wollt und haben uns auch sehr gute Bedingungen gemacht.
Also die sollte ursprünglich noch on-premise sein quasi
und die habt ihr dann erst mal abgesagt.
Genau, die war Ende letzten Jahres schon angekündigt.
Aber da haben wir dann auch gesagt,
nee, machen wir nicht, sagen wir alles ab.
Dann haben wir zwei Konferenzen dieses Jahr veranstaltet
und zwar ganz, als es anfing, die Oxidize 1K,
10 mal 10 mal 10, 10 Talks, 10 Euro, 10 Minuten pro Tag.
Um das einfach mal auszuprobieren, das war wirklich so,
erste Woche Lockdown, wir organisieren mal in der Woche eine Konferenz
und schauen mal, wie weit es geht.
Und dann halt eben die Oxidize-Conf im Juni.
Anwesend war ich auf der Rust-Conf und eben halt auch auf dem Rust-Fest.
Ansonsten habe ich die Gelegenheit genutzt,
dass man jetzt Konferenzen auch mal so teilweise anschauen kann.
Bei der MS-Build hat ein Freund von mir gesprochen,
Da hab ich halt da mal reingeguckt und hab dann noch ein, zwei Talks mehr gesehen und so.
Und hab auch einen Online-Vortrag gehalten, obwohl ich dieses Jahr eigentlich keine Vorträge halten wollte.
War die MS-Bild freizugänglich oder musstest du da auch ein Ticket für haben?
MS-Bild war freizugänglich.
Ich glaub, das wird auch so bleiben.
Also diese großen Marketing-Konferenzen, die haben festgestellt, ach, statt 2000 Leute oder 10.000 Leute hierher zu fliegen, können wir auch einfach 100.000 über den Stream erreichen.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Ja, definitiv sehr praktisch.
FSBTC war dieses Jahr ja auch in der
Richtung gehalten. Es gab natürlich nichts vor Ort
im Juni und wir haben auch recht früh
schon abgesagt. Im Nachhinein lässt sich das immer
einfacher sagen, im Juni hätte man nichts machen können,
aber ihr habt es ja sicherlich auch gut
gemerkt, wo ihr noch gehadert habt, dass man
zu der Zeit halt nicht wusste, wie es dann wirklich ausschaut
und wie es jetzt weitergeht.
Gut, dass das jetzt das ganze Jahr gedauert hat, das hätte man
Anfang des Jahres überhaupt nicht
absehen können oder gedacht.
Könnt ihr euch noch an flatten the curve erinnern?
Lein bisher.
Ich konnte mich bis eben nicht mal dran erinnern,
dass es die Oxidize 1K gab
und ich war an der mitbeteiligt.
Das war aber auch so die erste Konferenz,
wo ich mitbekommen habe,
beziehungsweise es gab plötzlich diesen GitHub-Account
oder Twitter-Account Homeforenses,
wo irgendwie gesammelt wurde.
Da wurde erst aufgezählt, was ist denn jetzt abgesagt?
Was ist abgesagt?
Dann plötzlich kam, das ist abgesagt, das ist abgesagt.
Die Liste wurde immer länger.
Und dann gab es dieses schöne Stichwort Homeforences.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer das organisiert hat.
Und plötzlich wurden diese Sachen alle ins Netz verlegt.
Genau, aber es war ja zum Beispiel auch für dieses Jahr
das Rustfest in den Niederlanden geplant.
Daran warst du beteiligt, Daniel, oder?
Also erst mal kann ich dir kurz sagen, wer die organisiert hat.
Das ist der Markus Tucker.
Der arbeitet bei Nordic in Trondheim,
macht ein bisschen für die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit
und ist da relativ umtriebig.
umtriebig. Der hat
unter anderem auch Sokrates und so weiter
diese Konferenzen
veranstaltet, macht viele Barcamps
und ist da recht aktiv.
Der hat was organisiert, genau?
Den Home-Ferences-Account. Ah, geil.
Okay, danke. Genau.
Credit where credit's due.
Warte ich mal verlinken.
Ja, und zum Rust-Fest.
Tatsächlich hatten wir letztes
Jahr im November das Rust-Fest
in Barcelona.
Dort angekündigt, dass es
das nächste Rustfest in den Niederlanden geben wird.
Und zusammen mit Leuten, die bereits in Barcelona dabei waren,
haben wir dann quasi, seitdem wir zurück waren aus Barcelona,
an der Konferenz gearbeitet.
Und als es dann im Januar, Februar losging mit den ersten Meldungen,
dass die ersten Länder eben einen Lockdown machen
oder davon betroffen sind, kamen bei uns die ersten Gedanken auf.
Wir hatten aber im Februar den allerersten festen Termin eingeloggt
für unser Rustfest Niederlande.
Der hätte tatsächlich im April sein sollen.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten wir aber von uns aus gesehen das große Glück.
Wir hatten noch keine Verträge für das Venue unterschrieben.
Und von daher, mit fortlaufender Zeit
fiel es uns dann zumindest organisatorisch einfacher,
das ganze Ding wieder abzusagen,
weil eben keinerlei finanzielle Einbußen zu dem Zeitpunkt für uns gab.
Das war sehr praktisch.
Für uns war es tatsächlich sehr praktisch,
denn das Rustfest ist eine Konferenz,
die komplett von Leuten organisiert werden,
die das nicht professionell machen.
Entsprechend wollen wir natürlich nicht,
dass irgendjemand daran finanziell zugrunde gehen muss,
wenn eben solche Kosten anfallen.
Selbstverständlich ist unser Budget und unsere ganze Planung darauf ausgelegt, dass das nie passiert.
Aber dass man ein komplettes Ding absagen muss aufgrund einer Pandemie, ist natürlich in keinerlei Risk Calculation irgendwo vorher aufgetaucht.
Wie macht ihr das eigentlich strukturell? Habt ihr da einen Verein, der das Ganze trägt?
Das ist tatsächlich bis zuletzt eins der großen Probleme gewesen des Rustfest-Projekts.
Dafür muss ich ein bisschen ausholen. 2016 hat Florian mich gefragt, ob ich nicht ein kleines Rust-Event veranstalten möchte, nachdem ich 2015 meine erste Konferenz organisiert hatte.
Und dann haben wir das Ganze gestartet in Berlin mit einer Konferenz, die ging zwei Tage. Die hatte an die 200 Leute, 150 Leute, so um den Dreh.
War das nicht nur 70 oder so?
Nee, nee, wir hatten schon, ja, genau, wir hatten schon.
Das war bei Microsoft das, ne?
Genau. Und damals hatten wir tatsächlich begonnen, wie stellen wir das überhaupt auf die Füße, wer trägt das Ganze und der ursprüngliche Plan war tatsächlich, einen Verein oder eine Organisation zu gründen, die das Ganze auch rechtlich abfangen kann.
Allerdings ist das hinterher gescheitert und wir haben dann, oder Florian hat dann tatsächlich eine neue Firma gegründet, was in Deutschland sehr viel einfacher ist, als einen Verein zu gründen.
Um eben, damit wir solche Dinge wie ein Konto haben, damit wir Verträge eingehen können mit Sponsoren oder auch dem Venue etc.
Und diese Firma existiert quasi immer noch, ist aber gar nicht mal mehr der Hauptträger des RustFests, sondern dadurch, dass wir es durch Europa geschoben haben, haben wir jeweils lokale Organisationen erstellt oder benutzt, um eben die rechtliche Seite davon abzusichern.
Aber nach diesem Rustfest Global dieses Jahr wollen wir das Ganze endlich auf festere Beine stellen, die auch langfristig für uns einfacher wartbar sind und haben das Ganze das Rustfest-Projekt genannt, in dem wir jetzt versuchen wollen, alles, was wir in nun vier Jahren Konferenz organisieren gelernt haben, alles mal in einem Projekt zu wandeln,
die Entscheidungswege transparenter darzustellen
und eben auch eine rechtliche Grundlage zu schaffen,
mit der wir das Ganze auch in Zukunft organisieren können.
Das klingt ziemlich cool.
Also es sollte ursprünglich Rustfest Niederlande werden.
Und ab welchem Zeitpunkt hattet ihr dann die Entscheidung getroffen?
Oder wann war für euch klar, ihr müsst jetzt das Konzept ändern
und irgendwie was anders machen?
Ist das mit dem Globy überhaupt erst daraus entstanden,
dass es überhaupt nicht lokal ging?
Dass ihr euch gedacht habt,
dann können wir es auch gleich für die ganze Welt machen?
Oder kam da noch irgendwie was anderes mit ins Spiel?
Es kam alles ein bisschen zusammen.
Wir haben, ich glaube, im März intern für uns klargemacht,
im April werden wir keine Konferenz organisieren können.
Schlicht und ergreifend, weil Deutschland im Lockdown war,
Niederlande war im Lockdown.
Es war klar, dass das Ganze bis in den Sommer hinein mindestens reichen wird.
Und Rustfest als durchaus internationale Konferenz kann es natürlich nicht verantworten,
Leute einzufliegen, wenn es völlig unklar ist,
wie diese Leute gesund und heile nach Europa kommen sollen
oder aus Europa wieder raus.
Von daher war für uns klar, das wird abgesagt.
Und dann haben wir angefangen, mit den Gedanken zu spielen,
was sind denn die Alternativen.
Auf dem Tisch war natürlich, wir schieben das Ganze um ein Jahr
in der großen Hoffnung, dass 2021 das Ganze wieder besser aussieht.
Das ist auch nach wie vor auf dem Tisch,
aber es gab trotzdem noch Leute in der gesamten Gruppe,
die etwas machen wollten.
Und dann haben wir angefangen, die Szenarien durchzuspielen.
Was können wir denn machen?
Wir hatten ein klein bisschen Erfahrung mit Online-Events.
Wir haben natürlich gesehen,
dass andere Events bereits online stattfinden.
Wir haben bei vorigen Konferenzen bereits Livestreams angeboten.
Das heißt, wir hatten durchaus Know-how und Zugang zur Technik,
um zumindest die Basics einer Konferenz irgendwie online zu kriegen.
Aber wir haben dann rumgespielt mit Ideen,
wie wäre es möglich, beides zu machen?
Können wir eine kleine Konferenz lokal machen mit einem Online-Part?
Die Idee wäre dann gewesen, wenn es über den Sommer wieder besser aussieht
und im Herbst das Ganze vielleicht stabiler ist,
dass wir ein kleines Event in den Niederlanden machen
mit 50, 100 Leuten, so in dem Dreh, aber einem Online-Part.
Wir haben dann aber auch drüber nachgedacht,
warum dann nur ein Ort?
Warum können wir nicht viele kleine Orte machen?
Hier und da einfach zusammen mit Meetup-Organisern zusammenarbeiten
und jeweils 20 Leute zusammenbringen oder 50 Leute zusammenbringen.
das wiederum hätte vielleicht
einige Sponsoren
auf die Platte gerufen, weil wir
dann sagen können, hier der Sponsor stellt
einen Raum, dafür ist er einer der Hauptsponsoren
und da können 50 Leute hin
aber auch irgendwann war
klar, zum einen
ist es unwahrscheinlich, dass wir mit gutem
Gewissen auch 20 Leute zusammenbringen können
und zum anderen
hat man, oder haben wir
glauben wir nicht
oder
war, wenn wir dann 20 Leute an
fünf verschiedenen Orten zusammenbringen, dann
haben wir fünf Events, aber nicht eins.
Die gucken im Zweifel vielleicht
den gleichen Stream, aber
es ist unglaublich schwer, diese Teile dann miteinander
zu verbinden.
Und außerdem
sind wir dann weiterhin quasi auf
eine kleine
Zeitzonenbandbreite beschränkt,
denn es ist unwahrscheinlich,
dass wir dann irgendwie Leute mitten in der Nacht
dazu aufwecken können.
Das ist das, was ich jetzt an dem RC3 als Experiment spannend finde.
Das sind viele kleine Airfas beteiligt.
Ich stecke da auch eigentlich überhaupt nicht drin.
Aber es gibt ja ein paar, die sich tatsächlich vor Ort treffen
und gemeinsam Stream schauen, wie auch immer das möglich ist.
Und mich würde mal interessieren, was nächstes Jahr
oder was hinterher so als Rückblick davon hängen bleibt,
was die Leute da, mit was für einem Gefühl die Leute da rausgehen.
War das jetzt ein ein kohärentes Event
oder war das bloß eine von vielen Online-Conferences,
wo wir bloß die Streams geguckt haben?
Jetzt bin ich mir gespannt, was davon hingleibt.
Also ich denke mal, für Leute wie mich,
die in der Schweiz oder in Österreich leben,
ist das sowieso eine Online-Konferenz,
weil in beiden Ländern ist effektiv ein Lockdown,
auch wenn die Regierungen das zum Teil nicht so nennen.
Also in der Schweiz redet man von Slowdown.
Ja, aber wenn man alle Vereine und Geschäfte und so zumacht,
dann ist das effektiv ein Lockdown, wo du spazieren gehen darfst
und Glühwein trinken auf der Straße.
Das wird eher ein deutsches Gefühl werden, wenn das dann durch ist.
Ich bin verhalten optimistisch an der Stelle.
Ich bin relativ froh, dass es erst mal gut geklappt hat,
Konferenzen überhaupt abzusagen.
Das war ein Teil von dem,
den ich im Frühjahr gemacht habe.
Es war viel Solidarität zu sehen.
Also inklusive,
ich habe einigen Leuten,
denen es schlechter ging als uns,
auch geholfen,
die halt vor der Insolvenz standen.
Also nicht vor der Privatinsolvenz,
aber so ein insolventer Verein
ist jetzt halt auch kein Spaß.
Das darf man immer nicht vergessen.
Konferenzorganisatoren sind halt
nicht einfach nur Organisatoren,
sondern da sind größere Geldmengen da.
Und wenn die ausbleiben,
dann redet man schnell
über wirtschaftliche Folgen
von 20.000 bis 30.000 Euro mindestens mal.
Da waren Konferenzen dabei.
Eine zum Beispiel, die hatten 475 Attendees,
durften in den Raum und in der Stadt wurden Sachen
über 500 Leuten untersagt.
Die waren also 25 an der Grenze dran.
Dann hat die in Eurovenue gesagt,
naja, ihr müsst ja nicht absagen, also bitte hier Geld.
Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum viele Konferenzen,
das fand ich ein bisschen schwierig,
nicht offiziell abgesagt wurden.
Die haben auch den Ticketverkauf nicht zugemacht.
Das war auch bei der Oxidice so.
Bei der Oxidize war während, wir haben zwar gesagt, Leute, wir gucken alles an, aber wir haben öffentlich nichts gesagt.
Schlicht und einfach, weil wir noch nicht wussten, wie die Venue reagiert und die haben sehr genau auf die Ticketverkäufe der Konferenzen geschaut, nämlich wenn der Ticketverkauf zugeht, dann sagen die, naja, ihr habt euch ja schon entschlossen zuzumachen, bevor ihr die Konferenz nicht stattfinden lassen musstet.
Insofern habt ihr die Entscheidung zur Absage ja schon vorher getroffen.
Da sind auch die Venues mit spitzen Bleistiften unterwegs gewesen.
Aus gutem Grund.
Denen geht natürlich auch die Muffe.
Ob es nur die Organisatoren sind oder die Venues,
irgendwer wird zu diesem Zeitpunkt auf seinem Geld sitzen bleiben.
Exakt, genau.
Aber da habe ich vielen empfohlen,
trete einfach direkt an eure Sponsoren ran und sagt,
wir machen stattdessen was online
und wir können das wirklich nicht machen.
Und seid euch dessen bewusst, wenn ihr eure Gelder zurückzieht,
dann sind wir pleite.
Und da haben die Sponsoren dann auch gesagt,
naja, was soll man sonst machen?
Und stattdessen sich halt auch
gesagt, wir sind in derselben
Super wie ihr, also das habe ich allen empfohlen,
so tretet an die Sponsoren ran und sagt einfach
direkt offen, wir sind in genauso
einer schlechten Situation wie ihr, wir überlegen
uns irgendwas und ihr müsst ja auch,
die Sponsoren sind ja nicht einfach nur
wegen dem Spaß da, also gute Sponsoren sind meiner Meinung nach
da, weil sie irgendwas erreichen wollen, wegen dem
Werbeeffekt oder sonst was und der
fällt ihnen ja auch weg und da auf die
Sponsoren zuzutreten und zu sagen,
wir machen das jetzt online
und wir überlegen uns da was für euch
und das wird alles ein bisschen roh.
Und zu meinem Verhalten
und Optimismus dazu kommen,
wozu das halt auch geführt hat,
ist erstmal die Feststellung,
dass unsere Online-Tools schlecht sind
für solche Sachen.
Also lange Zeit waren die Online-Tools
halt wirklich nur,
hier ist ein Videostream,
kannst du gucken.
Und das war halt eine Online-Konferenz.
Also es ist ja die Beschwerde überall.
Online-Konferenzen sind ja irgendwie
nicht so das Feeling von einer,
von einer Vor-Ort-Konferenz
und da mussten dann erstmal viele Sachen gebaut werden.
Und deswegen war zum Beispiel Oxidize 1K bei uns,
ehrlich gesagt, die Validierungsidee,
wenn wir jetzt im Juni eine Konferenz machen müssen,
dann lass uns doch vorher mal kurz was machen,
wo wir wenigstens ausprobieren können,
ob das überhaupt auf irgendeine Art und Weise funktioniert.
Wir haben dabei mehrere Sachen festgestellt.
Das eine ist erstmal, lange Vorträge bei Online-Konferenzen
sind richtig, richtig schwierig.
Da hat man ein Konzentrationsproblem.
Und man muss sich überlegen, was man inzwischen durch macht.
Und das hat man ja sowohl bei der Oxidize als auch beim Rustfest gesehen.
Wir haben bei der Oxidize 1K dann Sam Aaron eingeladen,
der genau dasselbe Probleme hatte.
Sam Aaron ist ein Musiker, den ich aus der Hubie-Szene kenne.
Ach, der Sonic Pi.
Genau, der Sonic Pi schreibt.
Den kenne ich über Kontakte über meine alte Konferenz,
bei der wir regelmäßig jemand anderen hatten,
der solche Sachen gemacht hat.
Und der hatte plötzlich das Problem,
der verdient sein Geld mit Auftritten auf Konferenzen.
Und das hat er dann auch nicht mehr.
Und hat mir dann einen echt guten Deal gemacht.
Hat gesagt, ich nehme ein bisschen Geld dafür.
Ich glaube ja immer sehr daran,
dass wenn man Geld bezahlen möchte,
dann sollte man auch gleich anfangen, Geld zu bezahlen.
Und mache euch da ein Set an dem Abend.
Und dann habe ich dabei auch gleich
mein ganzes Studio durchgetestet und so weiter.
Und jetzt spielt er auf der Github-Winu-Wars.
Jetzt kann ich ihn mir nicht mehr leisten.
Vielleicht können wir zu den konkreten technischen Problemfeldern und Lösungen gleich noch kommen, aber jetzt haben wir momentan, bloß weil wir gerade bei der Chronologie vom Rust-Fest Plus oder von der Oxidize 1K, so als ein Beispiel für Konferenzen 2020 sind, die bis zum Schluss irgendwie gedacht haben, oder wo die Organisatoren bis zum Schluss irgendwie gehadert haben, können wir es machen oder müssen wir es verschieben?
Dann gab es halt einige, die das Problem hatten,
kurz vor der Insolvenz zu stehen,
weil sie Probleme mit den Venues hatten oder mit den Sponsoren.
Habt ihr irgendwie ein bisschen mitbekommen,
wie die Sponsoren insgesamt so reagiert haben?
Haben die gesagt, nee, dann steigen wir wirklich aus?
Oder haben die teilweise mit sich reden lassen,
wenn es darum ging zu sagen,
gut, dann machen wir halt Werbung für euch in einem Clip?
Oder wie hat das funktioniert?
Also zumindest in der Zeit Mai bis Juni
war die Sponsorenreaktion sehr gut,
weil die natürlich vor eben genau demselben Problem standen.
Dass sie dann gesagt haben, okay, was sollen wir sonst machen?
Also wir müssen auch irgendwie überlegen, was wir tun
und wie wir Online-Repräsentanz machen.
Und man hat immer so das Gefühl,
Sponsoren sind immer überall hyperprofessionell.
Und das ist durchaus auch der Genuss, den ich diesen Sommer hatte.
Rohe Sachen funktionieren momentan total gut.
Also man sieht ja jetzt, wer weiß, wie viele Leute,
die halt einen Livestream haben,
wo sie einfach mal sich beim Coden zeigen und so weiter und so fort.
das ist alles nicht hyperproduziert
die Oxidase 1K war ehrlich gesagt
von der Produktionsqualität
schäme ich mich ja jetzt schon
sechs Monate später
aber zu der Zeit war es halt einfach
wir müssen mal gucken
wie das überhaupt alles funktioniert
statt einfach nur zu sagen, naja wir haben hier jetzt
halt einen Livestream und ihr könnt jetzt halt irgendwie
zwölf Stunden Livestream schauen und sonst nix
so
und das
finde ich das Gute
und dass das
den Schluss da zum Kongress
zu machen, ja, ich bin sehr gespannt, was die Leute da rausziehen.
Aber ich habe
also danke an alle, die da
irgendwas durchexperimentieren.
Also ich bin
nicht so der Kongress-Fan, weil
er mir auch ein bisschen schlecht liegt, weil das immer so
meine Downtime ist. Aber
ich habe jetzt einmal eine Stunde
Dauerwerbesendung geschaut.
Sie war großartig.
Es ist doch super.
Also, das meine ich eben mit roh.
Das kann man halt einfach mal machen.
Und die Hälfte davon stellt man dann fest,
naja, würde ich vielleicht doch nicht mehr machen.
Und die andere Hälfte, das würde ich doch wieder machen.
Insofern bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt, was davon bleibt.
Vielleicht können wir mal kurz ein bisschen einen Überblick schaffen,
was gab es denn so für Lösungen für Konferenzen dieses Jahr?
Also, wir könnten ja theoretisch mit der Oxidize 1K
als einem der frühesten Beispiele anfangen, was wir so kennen.
Also, es gab sogar noch eins davor,
von unserem alten Bezahldienstleister.
Die hatten auch so eine Testkonferenz
gemacht.
Wie hieß die nochmal?
Also die
haben ein Tool geschrieben, das für
Konferenz machen ist. Das hat so eine Art
integriertes Twitter gehabt.
Also ein besserer Chat mit Tagging.
Von Tito.
Genau, von Tito. Danke.
Da war ich dabei
und die Vortragsqualität war gut.
Aber es war halt
wirklich so, wie man sich das vorstellt.
Das war halt einfach
ein Chatraum mit allem.
Und ich glaube, das war so, dass der Swirman gesagt hat,
das ist das Minimum, was man gut machen kann.
Und ich glaube, danach wird es besser.
Ich glaube, man muss gar nicht
direkt zu den Konferenzen springen, wenn man
mal so durchgeht.
Im März
mussten wir die ersten
In-Person-Events
in Berlin absagen und wir haben ein
ziemlich gut funktionierendes Rust
Talk-Meetup.
das Rust & Tell. Das hat schon vor Ort immer irgendwas zwischen 30 und durchaus 70 Leute angezogen.
Im März mussten wir das quasi von einem auf den anderen Tag absagen und haben das Ganze einfach gesagt,
pass auf, wir haben die Speaker bereits, wir machen die Speaker einfach online.
Und was haben alle im März gemacht? Sie haben sich einen Zoom-Account geklickt
und alle Leute in den Zoom-Call geschmissen und dort das Ganze gemacht.
Das allererste Rust & Tell Online, was im März stattgefunden hat, hatte, ich glaube, 150 Zuschauer.
Das ist für so einen Meetup natürlich eine Menge.
Vor allen Dingen haben wir halt eine Menge Leute erreicht, die einfach nicht in Berlin sitzen, sondern die halt irgendwo saßen.
Und es war nichts anderes als, hier sind drei Talks und dann war eigentlich auch wieder vorbei.
Da haben sich dann plötzlich die Grenzen aufgelöst zu, wo ist das Meetup jetzt eigentlich? Also ich weiß, dass ich als Organisator von einem ganz kleinen Dresdner Meetup, dass ich mir gedacht habe, ich brauche eigentlich keinen Dresdner Meetup machen, weil es gibt ja einfach, das Berliner macht ja jetzt keinen Sinn, wenn ich die Leute eh nicht vor Ort einladen kann oder man sich eh nicht hinterher irgendwie direkt unterhalten kann, können wir das auch direkt einfach bei dem Berliner mitmachen.
Ja klar. Und was auf die Teilnehmer zutrifft, trifft natürlich auf die Speaker auch zu. Online bedeutet, ich brauche nicht darauf hoffen, dass irgendein cooler Speaker gerade in Berlin ist, sondern ich kann ihm einfach eine Nachricht schreiben und fragen, ob er zu Berliner Abendzeit vielleicht wach ist, egal wo er ist und Lust hätte, eine halbe Stunde zu reden.
Ich habe jetzt gerade festgestellt, ich habe auf dem Tokio-Tay-Rust-Meetup gesprochen. Das ist total angenehm, das ist mittags. Ich bin in der Mittagspause mal schnell zehn Minuten Lightning-Talk gehalten und bin jetzt gerade dabei, Leuten aus den USA zu sagen, hey, es ist doch viel einfacher, wenn ihr in Europa sprecht und Leuten aus Asien, es ist doch viel einfacher, wenn ihr in den USA sprecht. Könnt ihr das irgendwie zur Mittagszeit machen? Das ist ganz lustig.
Und ja, ich glaube genau, also wieder zurück zu dem, wo wir waren, also wie hat sich das Ganze entwickelt, welche Möglichkeiten gab es überhaupt? Also ich glaube, am Anfang haben alle erstmal gesagt, okay, alle sitzen zu Hause, wir müssen Talks machen, die können wir streamen, drumherum brauchen wir nicht viel.
Ich organisiere noch ein anderes Meetup hier in Berlin. Also an dem Rust & Tell war ich bis März diesen Jahres eigentlich gar nicht beteiligt, bis es dann eben online stattfand. Und ich organisiere aber das Hack & Learn in Berlin. Also ein Meetup, was ziemlich ohne irgendeine Agenda ist.
Leute haben sich immer für zwei, drei Stunden im Büro getroffen und einfach an Rust gehackt und in kleinen Gesprächsrunden einfach diskutiert.
Und auch das haben wir versucht online zu bringen.
Und auch da war das Erste, naja, komm, wir treffen uns in einem Zoom-Call, jeder mit Webcam und Mikrofon und quatschen einfach ein bisschen.
Und das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Ebene, als wenn man das vor Ort macht mit der gleichen Anzahl Leute, so zehn, zwölf Leute.
Weil in so einem Videocall kann man halt einfach nicht sich in Grüppchen aufteilen.
Das ist genau so eine große Frontalgeschichte, wo einer einen Vortrag hält und 200 Leute hören zu.
Das funktioniert auf diese Art und Weise eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber gerade diese kleineren Sachen, wo du eigentlich nur mit dem Typen oder dem Mädel oder der anderen Person links oder rechts von dir direkt reden möchtest.
Und mal kurz eine doofe Frage zum Thema Lifetimes stellen möchtest oder sowas.
Das funktioniert natürlich mit so einer Videoschalte nicht unbedingt.
Aber da haben sich ja jetzt auch das ein oder andere speziellere Tool,
was wir jetzt zum Beispiel auch gerade benutzen,
in dem Sinne entwickelt.
Bei der Oxidize 1K hattet ihr einen extra Matrix-Server aufgemacht,
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Und dann hattet ihr da schon für jeden einzelnen Talk
einen Channel oder wie hattet ihr das da gemacht?
Bei der I1K haben wir uns ein bisschen
übertrieben. Da hatten wir jeden
Talk einen Channel und dann hatten wir noch irgendwie 50
durchnummerierte Räume oder 30.
Wenn wir gesagt haben, da könnt ihr euch einfach reinsetzen.
So als
Breakout-Rooms, wenn ihr euch irgendwie in Gruppen zusammensetzen
wollt. Hat aber keiner angenommen.
Natürlich haben wir gesagt, ihr könnt auch eigene Räume aufmachen.
Das war kein Problem. Das war irgendwie der
Hallway-Track und da war quasi im
Hallway jede Ecke, hatte einen einzelnen Raum
und ihr hattet irgendwie die Leute dazu angehalten, maximal
fünf und dann
Ja, am Ende waren alle im General.
Man muss das ja mal ausprobieren, was dann funktioniert.
Die 1K war noch mit Zoom.
Später haben wir dann andere Techniken verwendet.
Ich bin ein bisschen unzufrieden mit dem Tech-Stack immer noch.
Also es wird alles besser,
aber man merkt an der Stelle wirklich ganz stark,
dass dieses Thema eigentlich noch nie richtig beackert wurde.
Einfach da dran, wie viel jetzt gerade entwickelt wird an dieser Stelle
und wie sehr neue Techniken aufkommen.
Also die Geschichte von Zürich Meetup war,
die hatten andere Meetups gesehen und viele hatten auch professionell,
also in der Firma, hatten halt plötzlich diese ganzen Zoom-Konferenzen
und da kam das Zoom-Bombing auf und wir hatten da ziemlich Schiss davor.
Und da haben wir am Anfang sehr viel experimentiert,
in dem wir gesagt haben, okay, wir haben zum Beispiel ein Meetup gemacht,
wo ich der Moderator war.
Ein Freund von mir gab den Vortrag
und ein dritter Freund war der OBS-MC-Betreiber.
Und am Schluss haben wir das auf Twitch und YouTube raus.
Nein, nur Twitch.
Wir haben dort nur Twitch gemacht.
Da haben wir verschiedene Konstellationen ausprobiert.
Ich kann sagen, wenn jeder bei sich zu Hause ist,
über das Internet, geht gut.
Und dann haben wir einmal versucht, wir machen so ein Studio.
Das heißt, wir treffen uns alle im gleichen Raum.
Das geht auch sehr gut.
Aber was nicht geht, ist alles auf einem PC machen.
Die Streaming-Tools kommen da nicht klar.
Wenn du ein Mikrofon hast, das möchtest du gerne auch noch als Monitor haben.
Du möchtest auf dem Kopfhörer aber trotzdem noch irgendwelchen Remote-Content hören.
Also das ist schon die Tools sind dann ziemlich am Ende.
und ja, am Schluss haben wir uns
darauf geeinigt, dass man
eigentlich auch Sequenzen abspielen kann
und du siehst dann halt im Livestream
einfach jemand VLC reinzieht
und auf Play drückt
und in dieser Aufnahme schneiden wir das dann raus
also
das haben wir vor allem in unserem Porträt gemacht
so diese
30 Sekunden Moment, ich muss schnell
hasteln und so, das haben wir alles rausgeschnitten
und sonst
Ich bin ja am Anfang des Jahres
bei den ersten Konferenzen. Ich glaube, meine erste
dieses Jahr war die UI-Conf. Das ist so eine
Berliner Software-Entwickler-Konferenz, wo
es generell primär um Apple-Themen
geht, aber auch andere Sachen.
Also hat nichts mit UI-Design zu tun, auch wenn es so heißt.
Vielleicht kann man auch so was Talks nicht richtig halten,
aber darum geht es mir gar nicht.
Das war meine erste Konferenz dieses Jahr und da habe ich das erste
Mal Kontakt damit gehabt, dass Leute halt
pre-recorded Talks abgespielt haben.
Im ersten Moment wirkte das natürlich sehr weird
und irgendwie ein bisschen uncool,
aber im gleichen Moment, wenn der
der Vortragende dann im Wald sitzt
irgendwo, die Kamera auf sich
gerichtet hat und seinen Talk hält und
gleichzeitig, während er die Talk hält,
aber im Chat ist und
Fragen beantwortet, ist das schon irgendwie ein ziemlich
cooles Feature.
Das fand ich ganz geil.
Also ich glaube, gerade da,
also wie Florian schon gesagt hat,
die Tools wurden seit
Anfang des Jahres einfach rapide
entwickelt und ausprobiert und getestet.
Aber auch was den Content
angeht, selber wurde einfach sehr viel
mehr rum experimentiert. Was
ist überhaupt möglich? Was kann man auch mit
den Limits, die es
überhaupt, die jeder so hat,
was kann man da überhaupt produzieren?
Die meisten Leute hatten wahrscheinlich
bis Anfang des Jahres nicht mal eine Webcam
außer die vielleicht in ihren Laptops
verbaute, geschweige
denn Mikrofone.
Und im April
dann war es nahezu unmöglich, neue Webcams
zu kaufen. Die waren ausverkauft, ja. Genau.
Und dann haben Leute halt angefangen, rumzuexperimentieren.
Was ist denn dann noch möglich mit den Limits, die man hat?
Und ich glaube, also ich persönlich habe dann halt auch einfach mal rumgeguckt.
Ich meine, wir sind mit Konferenzen nicht die Ersten, die Videocontent produzieren,
sondern es gibt zig andere.
Also das klassische TV macht das seit Jahrzehnten.
aber Twitch und YouTube sind groß
und Leute produzieren da unglaublichen Content.
Und ich glaube, da muss man sich inzwischen auch für Konferenzen
einfach deutlich mehr abgucken.
Aber das eben auch in einer Art und Weise,
die halt für Speaker und für Hobbyorganisatoren von Events
überhaupt noch möglich sind.
Man muss jetzt nicht die große 2.000-Euro-Kamera anschaffen,
um guten Content zu produzieren.
Bei etwas habe ich gemerkt, was das Format ändert,
als Redner selber.
Du hast diesen Delay.
Wenn du pre-recorded machst, dann ist das okay,
dann weißt du, das ist dann auch eingeplant.
Aber wenn du einfach sagst, okay, ich nehme einen alten Vortrag,
ich verbessere den, mache noch ein Kapitel dran
und dann hast du dort drin so Fragen wie,
und wenn sie diesen Beispielcode anschauen, was ist falsch,
was könnte die Fehlermeldung des Compilers sein,
dann hast du von dir zum MC 2-3 Sekunden
Und dann durch das ganze Streaming
sieh dir durch nochmal 30 Sekunden
bis zu den Leuten.
Und da verlierst du einfach schnell eine Minute
mit so einer Interaktivitätsfrage.
Ich glaube, da wäre schon noch
Raum nach oben, also für die Tools jetzt.
Simulatanz ist ein großer Spaß.
Muss ja nicht Zero sein,
aber so unter 10 Sekunden
wäre schon ein Wahnsinn.
Ich bin ja immer so ein bisschen
ein Budget interessiert.
Eine sehr schöne Sache,
die uns das ermöglicht hat,
auch wenn wir zu Speakern sind,
ist Speaker endlich auch wirklich zu bezahlen.
So ein bisschen beachten,
viele Konferenzen und auch die Oxidat
haben ihre Speaker immer bezahlt,
aber das war normalerweise wie bezahlen
das Flugticket und das Hotel.
Der Grund dafür ist ein ganz einfacher,
der vielen Leuten immer nicht so bewusst ist.
man braucht eine andere Visumsklasse, wenn man für Geld
einen Vortrag hält.
Also, dass es für Speaker, die interkontinental
einfliegen oder unter Umständen halt
aus Ländern, in denen die berühmte
Passport Privilege nicht ganz so hoch ist,
ist das ein großes Problem.
Also, das ist schon so, dass ich zum Beispiel, wenn ich in den USA
einen Vortrag halten würde und ich würde Geld
dafür annehmen, muss ich dann entsprechend ein Business Visum
beantragen.
Und das fällt dann ja jetzt weg, weil das ist jetzt
ja eine Remote-Dienstleistung.
Und damit können wir ja auch einfach sagen,
ich glaube, wir haben dasselbe
Modell gefahren, wie glaube ich auch das Waspfest fährt.
200 Euro für euch
oder alternativ als Spende an einen
Verein eurer Wahl
und 200 Euro für eine Ausrüstung.
Also wenn ihr noch Ausrüstung braucht, dann
kauft einfach und schickt uns
die Rechnungen.
Generell arbeite ich in den Bereichen immer sehr gerne
auf Vertrauensbasis, funktioniert super.
Die Leute sind
eigentlich immer sehr vorsichtig, diese 200 Euro
gar nicht auszuschöpfen.
Wobei die ja extra dafür da sind.
Und gerade das sehe ich halt
als auch diese Entwicklung,
wenn man mal in den März,
April, Mai zurückguckt
und Recordings
der eventuell Live-Vorträge anguckt,
Leute
hatten schlicht und ergreifend keine guten Mikrofone
oder Webcams und das
sieht man halt an, das nimmt nicht
der Qualität des Talks selbst weg,
aber die Video-Qualität
oder die Sound-Qualität ist halt schon
teilweise geringer und das macht es halt auch einfach
sehr viel anstrengender, gerade über eine längere Zeit
sich Talks anzuschauen, wenn es einfach enorm schwierig ist,
dem Ton zu folgen oder dem Video zu folgen.
Und auch deswegen, das hat die Oxidize gemacht,
das hat das Rust Fest gemacht und das haben auch andere Konferenzen gemacht,
ist dieses explizite Budget, damit Speaker eben gerade da aufrüsten können.
Keiner will vier oder acht Stunden vor dem Computer
hocken und
ein 640 Pixel Bild
angucken mit einem Ton,
der schlechter ist, als wenn man
mit
Vodafone im Wald steht.
Schlechtes Bild
ist immer noch verträglich,
aber schlechter Ton ist wirklich anstrengend.
Beides Out of sync
ist besonders schlimm.
An dieser Stelle
kurzer Schauter zu Outer City.
Wir haben das, glaube ich,
in Barcelona
haben wir das erste Mal alle Rust-Fest-Talks
mit Audacity einfach die neu ist.
Und das hat ziemlich viel gebracht.
Und das Tool, falls ihr selber
eine verrauschte Aufnahme habt,
dann gibt es sehr einfache Tutorials,
sind ungefähr fünf Schritte,
zehn Minuten maximal pro Vortrag, also mitrechnen lassen,
kann Audacity euch den Ton
wunderbar bereinigen
und einfach für die Aufnahmen
für später. Danke.
Ja, wir nutzen das ja
für die Podcasts ja auch, beziehungsweise wir nutzen nicht Audacity,
wir nutzen ein Online-Tool namens Aufernic,
was aber auch von ein paar Sound-Nerds geschrieben wird,
die da sehr viel Spaß mit dran haben.
Das ist super toll.
Das meint Stefan tatsächlich.
Das haben wir auch genutzt, Aufernic, das Online-Tool.
Ah, okay.
Okay, dann vielleicht können wir noch mal kurz abrunden.
Also die Organisation von Vorträgen
scheint sich so ein bisschen eingepegelt zu haben.
Es gab auch schon vorher Erfahrungen mit großen Webinaren.
Klaas hat sich herausgestellt, so ein Vortrag aus der Konserve ist wesentlich einfacher und die vortragende Person kann auch bereits während des Vortrags teilweise schon Fragen in dem dazugehörigen Matrixraum beantworten oder sowas. Aber es gab auch weiterhin noch Vorträge, die live waren, je nachdem. Das scheint zu funktionieren. Was sind denn so eure Erfahrungen, was aber das ganze Drumherum von der Konferenz angeht?
Also Konferenz ist ja nicht nur, ich höre mir die Vorträge von den Speakern an, sondern Konferenz mit der wichtigste Aspekt für viele von uns, die zum Beispiel zum Kongress gegangen sind und nicht einen Vortrag dort angeguckt haben live, ist ja eigentlich alles andere bei so einer Konferenz.
Dieses, ich treffe die Community, ich tausche mich aus über Kleinigkeiten. Was habt ihr da so für Entwicklungen gesehen? Wie ist das so von unterschiedlichen Konferenzen gehandhabt worden oder was gab es da vielleicht für Iterationen für diesen Prozess?
Also, ich spreche jetzt wieder aus der Erfahrung der Organisation des RustFest dieses Jahr. Das habe ich eben schon nicht weit ausgeführt. Wir haben dann eben im Sommer uns überlegt, wie machen wir die Online-Konferenz.
Und im Spätsommer sind wir dann dazu gekommen, dass wir gesagt haben, eine Acht-Stunden-Konferenz macht keinen Sinn. Zum einen, die Leute derzeit haben teilweise schlicht und ergreifend nicht acht Stunden Zeit, auch wenn sie zu Hause sind, aber da sind eben auch alle anderen.
und selbst am Wochenende sich acht Stunden rausnehmen,
ist für viele Leute einfach nicht möglich.
Das heißt, für uns war klar, wir brauchen kürzere Vorträge
und es muss auch möglich sein, eben diese Abschnitte so
sich einfach selber anschauen zu können,
ohne an die Zeit gekoppelt zu sein.
Das heißt, für uns war der eine Punkt,
es muss durchaus möglich sein, das Ganze dezentral anzugucken.
Man muss nicht an die exakten Zeiten gekoppelt sein.
Und das hat dann wiederum direkt zum nächsten Punkt geführt.
normalerweise bringen wir halt zwischen 200 und 400 Leute
von der ganzen Welt an einem Ort zusammen.
Das bedeutet, diese Leute sind alle in der gleichen Zeitzone
und die sind alle morgens wach und die gehen alle abends essen
und danach gehen sie vielleicht noch was trinken
und dann gehen sie ins Bett.
Aber wenn es online ist, dann ist es eben nicht so.
Wenn ich hier aufwache, dann gehen meine Kollegen
an der Westküste in Amerika eben gerade erst zu Bett.
Und in Asien essen sie halt schon zu Abend.
Das heißt, diese Zeitkomponente ist eine ganz wichtige,
aber auch eine ganz andere.
Das heißt, man muss diese Leute auch irgendwie
über Zeitzonen hinweg zusammenbringen.
Und da kam fürs Rustfest dann halt die Idee auf,
was, wenn wir keine Acht-Stunden-Konferenz machen,
sondern drei Fünf-Stunden-Konferenzen back-to-back.
Dadurch kriegen wir halt Leute in jeder Zeitzone.
Keiner muss für acht oder zwölf Stunden da sein, keiner muss zugucken. Und wir erreichen, und wir können das halt auf diese Gegebenheiten in der jeweiligen Zeitzone zuschneiden. Und so ist es eben dazu gekommen, dass das Rustfest am Ende einer Konferenz wurde, die tatsächlich 21 Stunden lang lief, von Teams in drei, von drei verschiedenen Teams auf der Welt organisiert wurde.
Und gerade, ich glaube, dieser Zeitaspekt, die Zeitzonenunterschiede werden wir nicht wegkriegen, egal wie gut unsere Tools werden, aber dass man eben auf diesen Communityaspekt geht und sagt, da muss man die Leute eben da abholen, wo sie sind, das kann halt nur funktionieren, wenn man halt auch zeitlich flexibel ist.
Also ich kann das durchaus bestätigen. Acht Stunden, wenn du bei so einer Konferenz bist und dann morgens hingehst und einen Kaffee trinkst und dann kurze Mittagspause und dann geht es weiter zu nochmal drei Stunden Vorträgen, da kriegt man diese Zeit relativ gut rum.
Wenn man zu Hause ist, ich hatte beim Rustfest Global noch Nachbarn eingeladen und wir haben zusammen die Vorträge geguckt, aber da hält man es ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz so lange aus, wenn man bei sich zu Hause sitzt. Da fallen einem noch andere Sachen ein, da gibt es einfach mehr Ablenkung.
Und dann hat man aber gesagt, gut, okay, dann gucke ich den letzten Vortrag dann einfach später.
Und dieses, ich warte noch, ich setze mich noch in einen weiteren Vortrag, weil wir hinterher noch ein Bier trinken gehen, das ging ja eh nicht.
Insofern war es schon ganz gut, das ein bisschen einzukürzen auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube, die größte Diskrepanz habe ich dieses Jahr beim Kongress, wo man in den letzten Jahren so um 10 Uhr in der Früh da war und um 3 Uhr in der Nacht gegangen ist, um einen Schlafplatz zu suchen.
Und das dann den nächsten Tag wiederholt hat.
Oder man ist einfach da geblieben, weil das lustig war und hat die Nacht ganz dort verbracht.
das geht natürlich
und dieses Jahr
sitze ich da und mache so zwei Stunden mit
und dann ist es doch irgendwie anders
jetzt, ganz anders
das Feeling von zu Hause, komplett anders
Ich war ja nur auf den Hamburger Kongressen
und da muss ich sagen, da war ich doch häufiger draußen, weil Hamburg
auch einfach eine geile Stadt ist
Kurze Kongresserinnerung übrigens, ich habe
dann das nächste Jahr in Hamburg
bei einem Kunden verbracht und war häufig
in dem Hotel direkt in dem Kongresszentrum
weil sie es ja abgerissen haben, deswegen war das
billig, auf den Seiten.
Das heißt, ich durfte regelmäßig
den Vortragssaal dabei sehen, wie sie ihn langsam
abtragen.
Was noch geht in Saar 1 und was nicht geht in Saar 1.
Ja, mein
erstes Bild dazu war, die hacken ja immer noch,
aber gut.
Das war
eine lustige Erinnerung,
als jetzt so langsam der Raum frei wurde,
indem wir es als Hemmlinger anstalteten ab.
Vielleicht noch aus der Sicht
als MC. Ich habe das erste Mal
MC gemacht beim Rustfest Global.
Und wir haben ja gewusst,
wir haben die Übergabezeiten.
Also bei uns ging es um 10 Uhr in der Früh los.
Japan hat
um 2 Uhr in der Nacht die Konferenz
gestartet.
Und wir hatten dann von 10 bis 18 Uhr.
Und ab 18 Uhr war der dann Latam.
Und wir haben uns so organisiert, wir waren drei MCs.
Und ich war
dann wirklich mitten in der Konferenz
einkaufen.
Habe ich oft Spätzle und ein bisschen Gemüse.
Dann bin ich kurz heim, habe ich reingeschaut, alles gut.
Ja, gut, dann gehe ich kochen.
Habe mich da mit dem Zweitlaptop in die Küche reingestellt, gekocht.
Und dann bin ich mit Essen wieder zurückgekommen.
Und das war viel weniger stressig, als wenn du in der echten Konferenz bist.
Dann hast du deine Lieblings-Koffeinhaltigen Getränke.
Du machst einfach durch von sechs in der Früh bis zum Abend um sechs oder sieben.
Da wird man aber auch verpflegt.
Da muss man sich nicht selber um die Mate
kümmern und nicht selber um das Mittagessen oder das Frühstück
kümmern.
Auf der anderen Seite,
ich glaube,
ein großer Fehler, den viele Konferenzen
machen, ist, dass sie versuchen,
das Vor-Ort-Feeling zu
replizieren und zum Beispiel zu sagen,
wie kriegen wir die Leute eigentlich dazu,
acht Stunden in den Monitor zu schauen?
Und da würde ich einfach
die Gegenfrage stellen, how about no?
Das sollte man nicht tun.
Also
ich weiß, dass
viele Konferenzen sich gerade im Sommer
genau diese Frage gestellt haben.
Wie können wir das Vor-Ort-Feeling
replizieren?
Ich glaube, sich aus dieser Frage
einfach mal rauszubewegen und sich davon
zu lösen, zwischendurch
war es bei der Oxidice
so, dass wir mal kurz verboten haben, das Ding
Konferenz zu nennen.
Auch wenn es am Ende
gerade in dieser Frühphase sehr konferenzähnlich war,
was wollen wir eigentlich als Online-Erfahrung anbieten?
Ja, das war so meine Frage.
Also wie löst man dieses Problem?
Es gibt das Problem, dass man Speaker hat,
dass die irgendwie ein anständiges Mikro haben,
das ist irgendwie lösbar,
dass die Leute Vorträge halten
und sich 200, 500, 2000 Leute diese Vorträge anhören
und das irgendwie gestreamt wird
und man irgendwie dazu Fragen stellen und Fragen beantworten kann.
Das ist irgendwie alles, ich möchte behaupten,
das haben wir irgendwie gelöst gekriegt.
Aber der Rest von der Konferenz,
was seht ihr da für unterschiedliche Lösungsansätze
und wie gut funktionieren die?
Also gerade dieser Hallway-Track oder dieses
ich treffe die Leute aus einem anderen Land
jedes Jahr auf der Konferenz oder sowas.
Also ich sehe zwei Probleme.
Also das eine ist erst mal Praxis.
Das heißt, Leute sind es nicht gewohnt,
auf solche Konferenzen zu gehen, sich dort zu behalten.
Leute sagen, es ist anstrengend.
Ich muss zum Beispiel mehreren Leuten erklären müssen,
dass das Ganze bedeutend weniger anstrengend wird,
auch mit Online-Meetings und so weiter,
wenn man sich ordentliche Kopfhörer kauft.
Man merkt, bevor man das nicht mal ein paar Stunden am Tag macht,
gar nicht, wie stark das stresst,
wenn zum Beispiel ein Kopfhörer oder der Sound rauscht oder so.
Oder wenn irgendjemand redet, der rauscht.
Am Ende mein Hirn gleicht das aus.
Aber das ist Arbeit.
Mein Audiofilter braucht auch Zucker sozusagen.
Die zweite Sache, und ich glaube, das ist ein ganz großes Problem,
ist, wir sehen wieder einen Rush auf geschlossene Plattformen.
Und das ist ein großes Problem, weil das nimmt die Flexibilität raus.
Ein ganz großes Problem, das man hat, ist,
also ich verwende ja an verschiedenen Stellen immer noch gerne Zoom,
aber Zoom eigentlich nur mit dem Begründungs-Connected überall
und das funktioniert gut.
Ansonsten ist das Tool richtig mau von der Bedienung her und von vielem anderen.
Aber es ist immerhin die Verbindung funktioniert.
Aber ein ganz, ganz großes Problem, das ich zum Beispiel sehe mit ganz vielen Tools,
ist, wenn du ein Problem mit dem Tool hast oder mal was hinzufügen möchtest,
bist du aufgeschmissen.
Es gibt keine Erweiterungs-API.
Du kriegst die Dinger nicht in Einzelteilen.
Also das ist ja eine der Sachen, die Rust Fest gebaut hat,
was wir bei der Oxidize mal kurz überlegt haben.
aber leider nicht hinbekommen haben.
Wir haben dann am Ende auf einen Cloud-Provider setzen müssen.
Und siehe da, dieser Cloud-Provider ist leider zum Beispiel
nicht blind accessible.
Und das war nun mal ein Problem, das wir hatten.
Wir hatten eine Person, die dieser Konferenz beiwohnen wollte,
was dazu geführt hat, dass wir einen kompletten zweiten Stack
und einen geheimen YouTube-Stream hatten für nur diese Person.
Und dann hat uns zwei Tage davor auch noch Matrix-Interface gewechselt
auf das neue Element, also von Riot zu Element.
und dann kam zuerst mal die Frage,
verwenden wir diesmal ein anderes Chat-Interface?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, es sieht nur ein bisschen anders aus.
Ja, ja, es sieht komplett anders aus. Schön.
Und wenigstens bei Matrix
haben wir da wenigstens halt noch ein bisschen Kontrolle darüber,
aber wenn du halt so einen,
wenn du so einen Anbieter hast und du nutzt ihn halt
und der ist nicht accessible oder er deployt mal
einen Tag vorher kaputt, dann kannst du dich in Support hängen,
aber das machen die innerhalb von 24 Stunden nicht.
Also,
ich werfe da mal
eine steile These im Raum.
Online-Konferenzen
sind viel unzugänglicher geworden,
weil Organisatoren
viel von dem, was du früher
flexibel machen konntest, also
auf einer Community-Konferenz kann ich hingehen, ich hab ein Problem,
da kann ich mir sogar jemanden von den Attendees schnappen
und sagen, ich hab grad hier niemanden, aber es muss mal ganz dringend
jemand da drüben
was machen.
Die meisten Leute dort sind
total cool und machen auch mal was.
Wir haben beim Rustfest vor Ort
immer das Lob bekommen, dass wir immer die Venues so
hinterlassen, weil wir beim Rausgehen sagen,
bitte räumt noch schnell
allen Müll auf und dann stehen fünf Leute auf
und räumen allen Müll weg. Das Äquivalent
dazu gibt es online nicht.
Schlicht und einfach, weil ich den ganzen Stack nicht unter Kontrolle
habe, wenn mein Streaming-Dienst, also
Streaming-Dienstleister gehen zum Glück noch, weil
Streaming-Dienstleister sehr generisch sind. Die nehmen auf der
einen Seite RTMP und auf der anderen Seite geht es
durch irgendein CDN irgendwo in der Welt raus.
Da habe ich dann vielleicht noch ein Problem, dass sie in irgendeinem Land
nicht verfügbar sind oder so.
Aber
es ist wirklich, wirklich schwierig momentan
für
Orga da die Qualität zu
halten und
was halt angeboten wird an großen Diensten,
egal, also
man braucht keine Namen
nennen, weil es ist für alle dasselbe,
die kommen mit ihrer
eigenen Idee, was so ein Event ist
und damit ist die komplexe Flexibilität,
die komplette Flexibilität raus.
Also das, was
jetzt hier zum Beispiel beim Kongress passiert
oder was halt auch so ein bisschen beim Rustfest passiert ist
und so weiter halt.
Wir machen da noch was dazu und
Sub-Events und so weiter und so fort.
Geht halt in dieser
Plattform, denke ich, nicht.
Ja, also Selbsttriptorien.
Also ich glaube, wir haben...
Das eine technische Bausteinchen,
was uns dort noch fehlt, ist, dass du
selber beliebiges
Zeug skalierbar deployen kannst.
Weil sonst läufst du immer so
in diese 50, 70 Personengrenze rein,
wo halt eine Maschine nicht mehr reicht.
Aber ich glaube, der Rest davon
müsste man eher so eine neue
Idee haben, weil
es ist kein physischer Event, du kannst nicht mal
irgendwas von A nach B verschieben.
Das kommt, glaube ich, wenn wir das Problem noch lange genug
haben, dann löst sich das Problem.
Sorry.
Ich habe nachher noch Ideen. Wir können ja nachher noch ein bisschen
sprechen über Ideen, was man machen könnte
in Zukunft.
Genau, also ich würde gerne
dann nachher noch zu einem Punkt übergehen, wo wir vielleicht
ein paar Zukunftsvisionen austauschen, was ihr euch so vorstellt.
Das können wir total gerne machen. Ich bin da super interessiert dran.
Ich denke nur wirklich,
das Problem ist,
dass dadurch, dass das Problem
so komplex ist, viele Leute
zu einfachen Lösungen greifen.
Und das ist der Teil, den ich an der
Konferenzorganisation sehr mag, nämlich eine gewisse
Kreativität. Und ich denke, wenn man
mal auf dem Rustfest war, merkt man das
so ein bisschen.
Es war immer bewusst ein bisschen
roh gehalten für die Möglichkeit, auch einfach
auf dem Rustfest Barcelona
habe ich jemanden dieses Audiointerface,
das hier jetzt steht, mitgebracht, weil der gesagt hat,
ich würde gerne einen Podcast machen. Ich komme aus den USA
geflogen, ich mache gerne einen Postcast, ich interview
ein paar Leute und so weiter.
Ich habe eine Universität,
wo ich den Hausmeister
mal noch einen Raum aufschließe.
Da verlangt auch keiner Miete für und so.
Sowas kann ich halt machen. Aber diese
Direktheit ist momentan
einfach nicht da und die bieten
keiner von den
Anbietern an und die sind dazu auch nicht
inzentiviert. Und ich glaube, das ist das große
Problem an dieser Stelle. Keiner von diesen Anbietern
ist eigentlich daran interessiert,
eine Plattform anzubieten, wo man
kreativ
sein kann. Und deswegen
würde ich sogar so weit gehen, dass ich
von allen Abrate und
allen Konferenz-Orga
empfehlen würde,
eigene Skills aufzubauen an dieser Stelle.
Das ist eine harte Nummer.
Also ich will,
aber ansonsten
enden wir halt genau in diesem Ding.
Dies ist eine Konferenzstil
mit einem Stempel drauf
von der entsprechenden Brand,
wo ich halt unterschrieben habe.
Also ich sehe es ähnlich. Also wir haben dieses Problem definitiv noch nicht gelöst und gerade jetzt in der Zeit, wo wir einfach dazu gezwungen wurden, Lösungen zu finden, sind natürlich viele Leute vorangeprescht und haben eben genutzt, was da war oder versucht, ihre Ideen von einer Konferenz eben einfach online zu replizieren.
Und das ist aus meiner Sicht halt eben genau die falsche Denke. Wir sollten nicht das, was wir aus der Offline-Welt kennen, replizieren, sondern wir sollten halt Möglichkeiten finden, die online besser funktionieren. Und wie vor, wie schon sich mal angesprochen, gerade dieser Community-Gedanke, der Gedanke, andere Leute zu treffen, ist eben ein großer Teil von Konferenzen.
Die Talks sind halt meist eher ein Grund, um mal alte Freunde oder neue Freunde zu treffen.
viele Konferenzen haben es dann eben einfach gemacht
und haben mindestens ein Chatsystem dabei gehabt.
Diese ganzen Videostream
oder Online-Konferenz-Plattformen
haben das meistens eingebaut.
Das wurde natürlich dann genutzt, aber aus meiner Sicht
hat das eben das Problem, es bleibt halt in diesem Tool.
Man ist daran gebunden, dass man
jetzt einen Mini-Klon
von Slack hat, der aber
noch viel schlechter ist als Slack,
weil man nicht mal auf Nachrichten
antworten kann, sondern einen großen Stream
von Nachrichten hat. Oder
man hat komplett eingebaute Lösungen,
die im Backend irgendwo
Matrix benutzen oder sogar
IRC benutzen oder irgendwie anderes, um
eben Textchats abzubilden.
Und ich glaube, da haben wir noch lange
nicht den richtigen Weg gefunden,
aber ich glaube, dass gerade
diese Verbindung mit einem Chat,
der durchaus textbasierend sein sollte,
mit der Erweiterung eines Video- oder Voicechats,
wie wir es jetzt auch haben.
Irgendwas dazwischen, glaube ich, ist was, was noch fehlt.
Und deswegen finde ich sehr spannend,
was der Kongress jetzt hier macht.
Sie sind sicherlich nicht die Ersten,
die das gerade ausprobieren mit so einer 2D-Welt,
in der jeder sich Räume bauen kann
und in der man rumlaufen kann
ein Video- oder Voice-Chat hat. Das finde ich
sehr interessant und
ich glaube, da müssen wir auch einfach noch mehr
in andere Bereiche gucken. Also ich meine,
im Grunde, was der Kongress hier nutzt,
ist ein 2D-Spiel.
Und Spieler haben diese Interaktion
von Leuten durchaus schon gelöst.
Ist auch
nicht jedermanns Sache, aber die haben halt
Lösungsansätze gefunden.
Und ich glaube, ähnliche Dinge können für Konferenzen
funktionieren. Wie genau das aussieht,
weiß ich aber auch nicht.
Das ist ja quasi so ein MMORPG,
was wir hier haben.
Und das ist ja ein Ding, was es schon lange gibt.
Ich hab mich schon seit einigen Monaten gefragt,
wie lange es wohl dauert, bis irgendjemand
Second Life wieder auskriegt.
Aber hat nicht Mozilla letztens genau so ein Tool rausgebracht?
Mozilla Hubs oder wie das heißt?
Da hab ich mein Geburtsort gefeiert.
Sehr cool.
Kann ich noch was zu sagen.
Der Kongress nutzt hier so eine 2D-Welt
mit angebundenem Jitsi.
Da muss man aber jetzt explizit
entweder beieinander stehen
spezielle Videobereiche reingehen,
um miteinander zu kommunizieren.
Das ist WorkAdventure.
Das ist ein Open-Source-Tool.
Wird offen entwickelt, läuft auf
WorkAdventure.
Punkt vor den letzten drei Buchstaben.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Ich kann es uns nicht sagen,
wie ich die Welt gemacht habe nachher.
Aber machen wir es praktisch.
Es gibt auch noch andere Tools, zum Beispiel
für das Rust Hack & Learn,
was ich hier organisiere, haben wir
ein Tool benutzt, das nennt sich
Town. Das
sieht im Grunde fast genauso
aus.
Hat im Grunde die gleichen
Funktionalitäten. Man hat eine kleine 2D-Welt,
kann rumlaufen und eben über
Voice und Video miteinander kommunizieren.
Was ich da sehr
interessante Aspekte finde, ist eben dieses
Positional Audio.
Das heißt, man hört andere Leute
oder sieht andere Leute nur, wenn man tatsächlich
neben ihnen steht. Und so
kann man eben auch Gruppen bilden, indem man einfach
mit seinem kleinen
2D-Charakter quasi an ein anderes Ende der Karte geht.
Und das wiederum repliziert halt diesen Gedanken des Hallway-Tracks,
dass man tatsächlich sich in Gruppen zusammenstellen kann.
Man kann auch Konversationen überhören, um sich dann eben einzubringen.
Und genau, wie du halt gerade erwähnt hast,
Mozilla Hubs ist quasi die 3D-Virtual-Reality-Variante davon.
Wird tatsächlich auch beim Kongress genutzt.
zwei, drei Hacker-Spaces oder ähnlich,
haben tatsächlich sich Mozilla Hubs-Räume gebaut.
Man hat da quasi eine 3D-Welt,
in der man eben sich bewegen kann
und eben auch mit anderen in Interaktion treten kann
über eben gerade Voice-Chat.
Und ja, Florian hat seinen Geburtstag da drin gefeiert,
weil wir uns eben auch nicht treffen konnten.
Sehr spannende Sache.
Fand ich eine sehr interessante Sache,
weil ich da natürlich mit vielen Leuten unterwegs war.
Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen ein Problem, wo man aufpassen muss.
Für viele Leute ist das momentan
die erste Online-Erfahrung.
Ich habe mal
noch Ultima Online gespielt. Das war das erste,
woran ich gedacht habe,
als du gesagt hast, MMO-RPG.
Das ist mehr Ultima Online als irgendwas anderes.
Als World of Warcraft.
Und
weil man in Ultima Online ja auch eigene
Welten erstellen konnte und eigene Regelwerke
und so weiter. Es gab ja dieses Chart-Konzept,
wo die ganze Spieleentwicklung
ja rausgegangen ist.
Deswegen finde ich es total interessant,
so vielleicht nochmal da in die 90er zu schauen.
Und was ich bei Hubs gemerkt habe,
ich habe auch dann gesagt,
ich feiere meinen Geburtstag
und lade die Leute um die ganze Welt ein
und setze mich hier irgendwie um 12 hin
und habe dann am Ende bis um 10 abends da gesessen.
Und es gibt ja diese berühmte Zoom-Fatigue.
Die hatte ich da gar nicht so.
Und ich erkläre das so ein bisschen dadurch,
halt eben dadurch, dass es relativ,
Leute schauen sich das immer an und sagen,
das ist halt eine 3D-Welt, sieht relativ mau aus
und die Avatare sind irgendwie ein bisschen komisch,
sind halt kleine Roboter.
Vielleicht könnt ihr mal kurz beschreiben,
für die, die Mozilla Hubs noch nicht kennen,
also das Work Adventure
oder das Gather Town
hat vielleicht schon mal jemand gesehen,
das sieht aus wie Zelda
oder diese Zwischenwelten
bei Super Mario Bros.
Und wenn man sich
mit seinem Avatar nah an jemand anders stellt,
geht plötzlich von der Seite ein Jitsi auf.
Darf ich, ihr habt den Problem damit,
wenn ich einen Screenshot von uns auf den Teppich mache
zu dem Podcast-Artwork von der Folge.
Da darf ich euch da screenshotten.
Kein Problem. Alles gut.
Nicht die Videokause, sondern nur das Work-Adventure.
Aber Florian, dann drück doch nach vorne,
dass du auch nach vorne schaust.
Wollte ich gerade machen.
Dann machen wir mal ein bisschen Arrangement.
Das ist hier nicht so wie Hoodie-Watt-Boy.
Ah ja, dass man es lesen kann.
Ja, irgendwie bin ich hier in der Jitsi-Pane.
Nee, nee.
Bisschen broken.
Mir mag er irgendwie nicht.
Also, ich nehme das mal wieder auf.
Also, es gibt jetzt diese Sachen,
wo man irgendwie durch so eine 2D-Welt läuft
und sich in den Kreis stellt
und dann fängt man an zu reden.
Das ist allerdings dann trotzdem
einfach bloß eine andere Art und Weise,
eine Videokonferenz zu organisieren,
weil im Endeffekt macht man damit
ein neues Arrangement auf
oder bei Wunder hieß es irgendwie ein Circle
und dann hat man mit den Leuten geredet.
Bei Gather habt ihr jetzt beschrieben,
hat man auch so ein bisschen aus der Entfernung was gehört,
das ist auch immer ganz praktisch,
weil was mir zum Beispiel hier fehlt,
ist dieses Rumlaufen, mal ein bisschen lauschen,
worüber wird denn hier gerade geredet,
möchte ich mich hier vielleicht mit dazu stellen
und mal über dieses Thema mithören,
weil mich das interessiert oder sowas.
Ja, es fehlt so das Grundrauschen von richtigen Konferenzen,
wenn du so in eine Halle reinläufst mit 2, 3, 5.000 Leuten,
dann hat das so ein Grundrauschen.
Ja, und LEDs, alles blinkt, das fehlt.
das haben sie repariert
also auf der CCC Instanz blinkt
ja aber es ist nicht das gleiche wie wenn die Halle blinkt
wenn man da rein geht
ja es fehlt dieser
super starke Laser dadurch
so und Mozilla Hubs
ist jetzt eine VR Geschichte aber ich habe mich mal
gefragt bei VR
habe ich dann überhaupt keine Kamera
quasi ich sehe nicht die echte
Person sondern nur den Avatar von der Person
genau das hat natürlich den
Vorteil dass ich nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwie Kamera
tauglich sein muss, während ich vor meinem Computer
sitze und ich muss
auch nicht hinterher irgendwie hier mein Sofa aufräumen,
damit ihr nicht seht, dass ich darauf eigentlich schlafe
und so weiter und so fort.
Ist das was, was ihr länger
aushalten würdet? Also ich beschreibe es
mal kurz. Also Habs ist dann
im Prinzip ein 3D-Raum
komplett im Browser
über WebVR,
nicht über VR, WebGL
und
über WebVR könnte man sich das dann auch
mit einer VR-Brille anschauen, wenn man denn eine hat.
ich hab keine.
Und da drin kann man im Prinzip rumlaufen,
wie mit einem 3D-Shooter.
Das ist, glaube ich, das größte Problem des Tools,
dass es davon ausgeht,
dass Leute mit einer Shooter-Steuerung zurechtkommen.
Das ist schon ganz schön inaccessible,
muss man sagen, für Leute,
die damit noch nie eine Erfahrung gemacht haben,
aber kommen schon damit zurecht.
Und da drin kann man dann einen beliebigen Raum reinladen.
Also das ist im Prinzip ein vormodellierter 3D-Raum.
Der hat ein paar Sachen.
Zum Beispiel kann man bestimmte Wandflächen markieren.
da könnte man noch was hinhängen, da komme ich gleich noch zu.
Aber ansonsten ist es
dann einfach ein beliebiger Raum.
Und da kann man verschiedene Einstellungen dran machen.
Eine Sache zum Beispiel,
und das ist ein wichtiger Teil, ist,
wie weit zum Beispiel Geräusche
klingen. Und dadurch kann man
dann halt einen Raum schaffen, in dem man halt auch an Leute
rantreten kann. Und was ich sehr angenehm fand,
ist, dass das halt wieder die Möglichkeit bietet,
also ist das grafisch?
Wenn man sich das anschauen würde, das ist so ein bisschen,
sagen wir mal, 2001
so von der Grafisch-Präsident.
nach Wii-Me aus. Genau.
Und viele von den Avataren sind halt so
irgendwie kleine Roboter und so weiter und so fort. Aber
eine sehr schöne Sache, und
das muss man einfach mal erfahren haben, ist halt eben
die Möglichkeit, sich wieder in den Kreis zu stellen.
Und wenn man redet, dann bewegen
die Avatare auch so ein bisschen sehr
exageriert den Kopf. Also der wird dann einfach
größer und kleiner. Oder wenn man einen Vogel
als Avatar hat,
sehr sichtbar, geht der Schnabel auf und zu und so.
Das gibt
einem aber halt gerade ein Gefühl dafür, wer redet
gerade? Und man kann halt wieder so Sachen machen wie
wir reden mal alle links rum.
Und das löst viele Probleme, die man in Videokonferenzen eigentlich hat,
nämlich gerade dieses, wer agiert eigentlich gerade hier am Tisch sozusagen.
Deswegen machen wir ja für sowas hier auch das Video an,
dass da irgendwie ein bisschen, wer als nächstes reden möchte, hebt die Hand.
Aber im Endeffekt hat man immer diesen Stuhlkreiseffekt.
Ich habe es auch gemerkt, am Anfang habe ich so ein paar Lockdown-Partys gemacht
mit Freunden, als du wirklich nicht rausgehen solltest.
Das ist ja eigentlich immer noch so.
Und da hat sich aber das Gespräch immer bloß zwischen ein, zwei Leuten abgespielt und der Rest hat zugehört.
Das ist so ein bisschen das, was nicht gut funktioniert.
Genau, und diese Kreisbildung, also mein Schluss daraus ist, wir haben uns zu sehr aufs Visuelle konzentriert.
Dieser ganze VR-Kram ist völlig uninteressant.
Wenn man es nur visuell betrachtet, das Audio ist der interessante Part.
weil wir ja doch sehr viel halt gerade so aus dieser Reihenfolge halt eben,
ich glaube, das ist das,
ich glaube, das beste Feedback,
das ich bekommen habe von einer Freundin,
die hat gesagt, ich habe mich präsent gefühlt.
Also es war halt ein Präsenzgefühl da.
Und das ist, glaube ich, das Problem
bei so vielen Zoom-Konferenzen und sonst was.
Und was Hubs dann halt auch noch anbietet,
ist, dass im Prinzip auf einem Hub-Server
kann man mehrere von diesen Räumen haben
und die kann man sogar verknüpfen.
Und dafür gibt es sogenannte Portale.
Diese Portale kann man zum Beispiel in diese Snappoints hängen.
Kann man sagen, hier ist ein Portal.
Wenn du draufklickst, kommst du in einen anderen Raum.
Und dann gibt es die Möglichkeit,
weil du wegen Video gefragt hast,
zum Beispiel zu sagen, ich würde gerne meine Webcam sharen.
Aber dann musst du das irgendwo,
dann kriegst du so ein,
du kannst Sachen in den Raum setzen.
Dann kannst du sagen, ich hätte hier gerne ein 3D-Objekt
und das würde ich hier gerne in den Raum setzen.
Und unter anderem gibt es halt auch das 3D-Objekt,
meine Webcam oder ein YouTube-Video
oder ein Video von irgendwas anderem und so weiter.
Und das ist schon relativ interessant.
Und dann steht man in dem VR-Raum im Kreis
und startet auf diesen virtuellen Bildschirm,
wo dann deine Webcam drauf zu sehen ist quasi.
Genau, kann man dann seine Geburtstagsansprache
auch wirklich in Raumgröße machen.
Ich will das fürs persönliche Ego.
Nachteil ist, das ist alles noch ein bisschen roh.
Also gerade so Snapping von Sachen aneinander.
Also zum Beispiel, ich habe versucht,
was auf den Tisch zu legen, mehrere Sachen,
hier eine Banane und so weiter und so fort.
Auf der anderen Seite, auch da wieder,
Leute sind momentan an sowas interessiert
und kommen mit solchen Unzulänglichkeiten
auch einfach zurecht und spielen damit rum.
Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, es waren so viele
von meinen Freunden da, die ich wahrscheinlich Jahre
vorher nie zu einem IP-Telefonie-Call
auch nur irgendwie hätte überzeugen können.
Und das ist eine Sache, die ich auch
von ganz anderen Leuten höre.
Ich hab mich vor kurzem mit jemandem unterhalten,
der ist im Klassik-Bereich unterwegs
und der hat gesagt, sie machen momentan Klassik-Konzerte online.
Und das ist jetzt die Zielgruppe,
die vorher halt wirklich jede Woche einmal hier in die Philharmonie gelaufen ist
zum Mittagessenskonzert, das hier kostenlos ist.
Ja, jetzt momentan halt nicht.
Und die sind jetzt plötzlich wie selbstverständlich online.
Obwohl Musik gemeinsam online machen,
ist nochmal ein ganz anderer Aspekt.
Machen ist problematisch, aber.
Die werden dann wahrscheinlich was abspielen oder die Musiker sind zumindest co-located.
Wie problematisch das Machen ist, hat man wahrscheinlich Anfang des Jahres schon mitbekommen,
wenn auf Arbeit das erste Mal im Videocall versucht wurde, für jemanden Happy Birthday zu singen.
Und das alles herrlich out of sync war.
Also das beste Konzert, was ich gesehen habe bisher, ich habe zwei gute Dinge gesehen,
eine war von ein paar Freundinnen, die haben sich einfach zusammen getroffen,
haben einen Riesenspaß gehabt, so nach dem Motto,
wir haben eine gute Zeit, wir freuen uns an unseren eigenen Konzerten,
wenn das Internet aussteigt, dann haben wir uns trotzdem noch einen Nachmittag lang vergnügt.
Und das andere war halt dann wirklich professionell gemacht.
Also wo dann die Musiker alle sehr gute Aufnahmegeräte hatten,
wo die Latenz auch wirklich runtergebracht wurde von irgendeinem Mixer, der in der Cloud läuft.
Aber das, ja, dann brauchst du halt wieder fünf Leute extra zu den Musikern dazu.
Das ist auch nicht praktisch für vieles.
Aber es geht.
Ich glaube, Musik ist einfacher, dass Konferenzen machen,
also das Beigemüse von der Konferenz,
als dass du mit Leuten sprichst.
Also ich fand diesen Punkt von Florian gerade spannend.
Wir haben uns so sehr auf das Visuelle konzentriert,
dass das Audio wurde bislang vernachlässigt.
Also bei Musik, nochmal, Musik ist, glaube ich, ein sehr schwieriges Thema,
weil du brauchst eine extrem niedrige Latenz
und wenn du eine extrem niedrige Latenz haben möchtest,
dann hast du bei einem gewissen Punkt
dann keine gute Audioqualität mehr.
Das ist ja wirklich,
dir irgendwie live mit jemandem zusammen zu spielen,
aber es ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt anhörbar,
weil du eventuell Buffer-Underruns hast
oder du musst das Encoding so schlecht machen,
dass es sich nicht gut anhört.
Das ist, glaube ich,
ein wirklich schwer zu lösendes Problem.
Aber allein diese kleinen Sachen,
wie wir von diesem Stuhlkreiseffekt wegkommen,
sodass wirklich alle auf demselben Audio-Mix sind,
Das wäre vielleicht schon mal eine Kleinigkeit.
Wie kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel
Kilian was zuflüstern, während
wir hier alle in diesem
gemeinsamen Chat sind?
Oder dass wir mal kurz
diesen Raum hier aufbrechen.
Wir hören uns zwar alle noch so ambient, aber
der eine redet in die Richtung, der andere redet
in die Richtung.
Habe ich das so
verstanden, dass das bei Herbst in etwas so funktioniert,
dass irgendwie der Ton auch davon abhängt, in welche
Richtung ich gerade rede?
Ja, also ein wenig. Also es ist eben da auch dieses Positional Audio, das heißt, es wird eben lauter oder wenn man einem Gespräch näher kommt und man kann auch zwischen der Richtung entscheiden, wo der Ton herkommt.
Und ich finde halt, das hilft schon ein wenig zusammen, ein bisschen mit diesem Visuellen, dass man überhaupt sieht, wer redet, hilft es eben einfach, dass man quasi genug andere Sinne noch stimuliert, damit es halt nicht genauso übermütend ist, wie wenn wir jetzt einfach nur alle mit der gleichen Lautstärke in beide Ohren konstant reden.
Das ist etwas, was einige Hersteller von Konferenzprodukten bereits ausnutzen tatsächlich, dass du, wenn du die Stimmen der einzelnen Teilnehmer im Stereospektrum von links nach rechts einigermaßen aufteilst, fällt es dem Gehirn wesentlich einfacher zu entscheiden, wer redet jetzt gerade oder auch selbst wenn zwei Leute gleichzeitig reden, kommt man damit relativ gut klar, sich auf eine bestimmte Richtung zu konzentrieren.
Wenn ich jetzt hier die Augen zumache bei so einem Podcast, wo fünf Leute drin sind, also ich werde jetzt bei der Aufnahme zum Schluss das wieder ein bisschen im Spektrum verteilen, unsere Stimmen, aber jetzt jemand, der zum Beispiel Jan-Erik und Stefan noch nicht kannte und die Stimmen vielleicht nicht gut unterscheiden kann oder sowas, da fängt man jedes Mal an. Ich merke das selber bei Podcasts, wo viele Leute drin sind. Man weiß nicht, wer redet jetzt gerade, wenn man es nicht sieht.
Das macht wahrscheinlich auch einen Riesenunterschied,
wenn man die Namen wirklich zuordnen kann,
dem Stimmklang. Wenn ich einen neuen Podcast
anfange, wo drei Leute das Ganze
erhalten, dann kann ich die Stimmen,
wenn ich Glück habe, gut auseinanderhalten,
aber ich weiß nicht, wer wer ist. Da fällt es mir schwer,
Dinge zuzuordnen, weil ich nicht weiß,
wer wer ist. Und wenn man
diese Zuordnung hat, dann fällt es einem viel leichter,
Meinungen auf die Gesichter oder die Namen
zuzuordnen. Und der Dialekt hilft auch.
Ich höre den alten Podcast, der ist super zum
unterscheiden, weil da sind Schweizer, Österreicher
und den Deutschen dabei.
Das geht auch sehr gut.
Klingt auf jeden Fall sehr markant in dieser Runde.
Das stimmt.
Ich könnte anfangen zu bälzern.
Ein interessantes Gegenexte bei dem Moment dazu ist,
Spatial Chat ist ein Produkt,
das die 3D-Welt weglässt und eigentlich nur so ein 2D-Chat hat,
aber halt gerade genau diese Sache macht.
positionales Audio
auf dem 2D-Kreis
zu verteilen.
Das funktioniert eigentlich auch überraschend gut.
Also gerade diese Hörerfahrung
ist an der Stelle durchaus wichtig
für Gruppen
Unterhaltung und das finde ich
einfach ein interessantes Feld.
Diese Produkte gab es
vor einem Jahr nicht und plötzlich fällt
Leuten auf, ah ja, irgendwie ist das doch alles
scheiße und
das
finde ich
Das finde ich ein total spannendes Thema momentan,
mit dem man sich lange Zeit beschäftigen kann.
Und ich hoffe, dass das anhält
und wir nicht noch eine längere Pandemie brauchen,
damit sich Leute mit dem Thema auch weiter beschäftigen.
Das fand ich etwas unnötig, sagen wir es so.
Ja, es muss halt erst wehtun, damit man was verbessert.
Aber vielleicht, ich schaue jetzt gerade in die Notizen
und ich schaue so ein bisschen auf die Uhr.
vielleicht wollen wir mal ein bisschen tatsächlich konkret darauf eingehen.
Du hattest ja auch dieses Gespräch hier vorgeschlagen, Florian,
weil du irgendwie über die Tools, was besser gehen könnte,
was gerade scheiße ist und was vielleicht noch verbessert werden muss.
Vielleicht wollen wir da mal direkt darauf eingehen.
Jetzt haben wir schon ein paar von diesen 2D-Tools
oder Mozilla Hubs vorgestellt, aber was fällt mir so ein?
Also, für mich, nochmal weg quasi von dieser Interaktion mit Beteilnehmenden, ein Problem, was ich aktuell sehe, ist gerade auch einfach die Video- oder Content-Produktion übers Internet.
Da sehe ich noch durchaus Bedarf, das zu optimieren. Die Tools, die es gibt, die sind schon ganz brauchbar, aber meistens ist es darauf ausgelegt, dass man entweder eine ganze Menge Hardware bereits zu Hause hat, aber das bedeutet wieder, eine Person muss das Ganze regeln.
Man braucht wahrscheinlich auch einen vernünftigen Upstream, um Video und Ton überhaupt reinkommen und rausgehen lassen zu können. Aber die meisten dieser Tools sind oft nicht darauf ausgelegt, dass Leute das dezentral managen können.
Diese Tools müssen mehr so online gelagert werden, dass man im Grunde nur auf einen Webinterface guckt, wo das Ganze gemanagt wird, wo unterschiedliche Leute es auch zeitgleich managen können, wo es eventuell noch einen Backstage- oder einen Orga-Bereich gibt, einfach um diese direkte Kommunikation im Hintergrund handeln zu können.
Und das ist was, was Tools, die wir ausprobiert haben, tatsächlich fehlt.
Eben weil wir, wir hätten Zugriff auf Recording Studios und Hardware gehabt.
Aber das hätte halt bedeutet, dass ich da sitzen muss.
Und das ist halt bei einer 21-Stunden-Konferenz unwahrscheinlich, dass man das durchhält.
Also, der gesamte Production-Prozess und jetzt mal schnell von dem Stream auf den Stream wechseln und zwischendurch irgendwie ein Jingle abspielen.
Genau, einfach ein komplettes oder zumindest teilweise das Video-Mixing, Audio-Mixing. Überhaupt die Möglichkeit, das große Problem ist natürlich, dass die Speaker auch irgendwo sind. Die Speaker haben auch nicht die Top-Hardware, die haben hoffentlich einen Laptop, was eine Kamera hat oder ein Mikrofon oder man kauft es dazu.
Aber die werden nicht den besten Upstream haben.
Das heißt, es muss so oder so durch einen Server,
bevor es irgendwie rausgeht.
Es muss aber auch eine Möglichkeit geben,
dass die Leute entsprechend überhaupt sich einwählen können.
Jeder hat einen anderen Laptop,
jeder hat ein anderes Betriebssystem.
Das heißt, ich will auch nicht jedem Speaker sagen,
hier installiere nochmal diese drei Tools
und klick da, da und da auf Verbinden,
damit alles ankommt.
Sondern jeder hat einen Webbrowser.
Es sollte irgendwie da tun, dass es funktioniert.
Und gerade da sind die Tools ein bisschen hinterher noch.
Also genau das, was die TV-Studios bereits vor 30 Jahren gelöst haben,
das brauchen wir jetzt dezentral, sodass alle dran teilnehmen können.
Wir brauchen es vor allen Dingen so,
dass man dafür nicht einen kompletten Van vom WDR vorfahren muss,
damit da halt ein HD-Signal rausfällt.
Ja, das stimmt. Okay.
Ein bisschen so in kleiner Form haben wir das ja ausprobiert.
Normalerweise machen Kilian und ich unsere Podcast-Aufnahme.
selbst wenn wir sie dezentral machen,
weil wir nicht direkt am selben
Mischpult sitzen,
haben wir die letzten Male immer über
Studio Link gemacht, aber das macht sich ja zum Beispiel
auch schlecht, wenn du Gäste hast, wo du mal eben
sagst, hier, möchtest du mal an meinem Podcast teilnehmen?
Hier, du musst dir dieses Tool runterladen,
so installieren und dann bädest du dich bitte auf die
und die Art und Weise ein.
Das haben wir jetzt im letzten Moment abgesagt, weil wir ein bisschen
Probleme selber damit hatten.
Was wir jetzt benutzen, würde ich
einfach mal kurz erwähnen, ist
Zencaster. Das ist komplett
Browser, komplett über WebRTC.
Scheint
ganz gut zu funktionieren bislang.
Ich hoffe... Gucken wir mal, bis du auf Stopp klickst.
Dann schauen wir aufs Becker.
Wenn ihr das hier...
Wenn ihr das hört, dann hat es offenbar
funktioniert oder Hendrik hat fünf Stunden
lang am Schnitt geschwitzt.
Danke dafür. Aber
genau solche Sachen wie das hier,
eine Lösung, wo sich drei Leute, fünf Leute,
zehn Leute einwählen und da könnte man vielleicht sagen,
die sind im Panel und können reden
und die anderen dürfen alle zuhören. Das ist halt auch nur ein,
weiteres proprietäres Tool, aber ich meine,
es funktioniert ganz gut und es macht
das eine, was das Gefühl noch gar
nicht gab, nämlich, dass wir alle
Lokalaufnahmen haben und eine Person, das
eben startet, am Ende Stop drückt und dann werden die Lokalaufnahmen
automatisch hochgeladen und das
ist das eine, was ich immer gesucht
habe für ein Podcasting-Tool,
aber es wäre schön, wenn es das
auch in den Offen und Cool gäbe,
noch dazu.
Ich habe
Riesenproblem mit proprietären Tools.
Da bin ich ein bisschen
utilitarian,
wie man im Englischen so schön sagt.
Es gibt zum Beispiel ein sehr schönes Tool,
das zumindest so ein bisschen Streaming-Boost macht.
Also hier mal
aus mehreren Input-Videos
zusammen auf eine
Bühne und das dann relativ schön macht
und so weiter und so fort. Das kann nicht viel.
Also ich glaube, wir brauchen vor allem Tools,
die nicht viel können, aber das
sehr gut machen.
die wir verwenden da, wie gesagt, für viele von unseren Sachen.
Die man vor allem auch kombinieren kann,
wahrscheinlich der Unix-Gedanke, wo man sagt...
Genau, und das ist eben der Punkt.
Da fällt am Ende ein RTMP-Stream raus.
RTMP ist ja an sich auch wieder proprietär.
Aber kann halt einfach zu allem, was halt irgendwie RTMP akzeptiert.
Und am Ende wird man auch nicht so richtig drum rumkommen,
außer man ist jetzt halt gerade sehr, sehr gut im Netzwerken.
Auf jeden Fall auf irgendwie auf den CDN zurückzugreifen,
oder auf irgendeinen Streamout-Dienst,
der auch wieder proprietär ist.
Man wird da nicht ganz drum rumkommen.
Irgendjemand muss für Infrastruktur bezahlen.
Wenn die Software frei ist, heißt das immer noch nicht,
dass sie auch irgendwo läuft und skaliert.
Ich bin auch bereit, für Software zu bezahlen.
Oder für Services.
Also wir haben beim RustFest
eins dieser Online-Tools verwendet.
Wir haben StreamYard verwendet.
Das ist auf der Seite der sehr simplen Variante.
was sehr toll ist, weil man eben nicht
komplett verstehen muss, wie funktioniert Videoproduktion
wenn man der Moderator oder der Speaker ist, braucht man einen Browser
und man muss sich damit verbinden und seine Webcam und sein Mikrofon freigeben und vielleicht noch
seinen Desktop sharen und dann funktioniert es und
entsprechend kann dann jemand, der den Admin-Account da hat, das Ganze
noch managen, man kann auch verschiedene Szenen auswählen, also Szenen-Layouts
und am Ende verbindet es entweder direkt zu einem der großen Plattformen,
also YouTube, Twitch oder ähnliches,
oder einfach zu einem angegebenen RTMP-Server.
Das Problem da ist, das ist eben auf der ganz einfachen Seite.
Es fehlen da eben die Erweiterungsmodi.
Es ist vor allen Dingen zum Beispiel nicht darauf ausgelegt,
dass es mehr als ein Admin gibt.
Es funktioniert, wenn man den gleichen Admin-Account
von mehreren Seiten aus nutzt.
Aber es ist eben nicht darauf ausgelegt.
Das heißt, wenn man sich nicht ordentlich abspricht,
dann hat man halt, und zwei Admins gleichzeitig da rumwerkeln,
dann passieren halt Dinge,
die vielleicht im Livestream nicht unbedingt sein müssen.
Also, dass die Szenen hin und her wechseln
oder dass Leute auch aus dem Stream fliegen,
wenn sie das nicht sollten.
Es ist auch vor allen Dingen nicht daraus ausgelegt,
dass man stundenlange Streams hat.
Also dieses Tool ist vor allen Dingen auf so Gamer ausgelegt
oder auf im Grunde so Twitch-Streaming,
wo man vielleicht mal eine Stunde oder zwei, wenn es Stream macht,
noch zwei, drei Leute einlädt, um über irgendwas zu diskutieren
oder ein Spiel streamt oder ähnliches.
Wo man halt nicht viel tun muss.
Am anderen Ende steht dann so Software wie OBS,
was halt jemand auf seinem Computer installiert und alles kann.
Aber beispielsweise, wenn ich das auf meinem Laptop aufmache,
dann kann ich den Laptop auch nicht mehr für irgendwas anderes verwenden,
weil das braucht scheinbar alle meine Kosten.
Inzwischen gibt es dann auch Software dazwischen.
Wir haben noch rumgespielt mit, ich glaube, es heißt Lightstream Studio.
Das ist fast wie OBS.
Genau, das ist quasi wie ein OBS im Browser.
Es funktioniert auch vergleichsweise gut,
aber man muss halt überhaupt ein tiefergehendes Verständnis haben
von wie funktioniert Videoproduktion und was tue ich da eigentlich.
Weil gerade dieser Wechsel, man muss erst mal seine Szenen zusammenstellen,
man kann alle möglichen Objekte eben in so eine Szene reinklicken,
man kann sie verschieben, wie man will.
Und das ist halt für Leute, die man nur dazu holen will,
um hier und da mal zu moderieren, einfach zu viel.
Und auch da oder auch bei diesen beiden Tools
fehlt eben auch wieder so ein Greenroom oder ein Backstage,
wo man halt sich über Video oder auch nur Voice
mit den Leuten eben abschmechen kann,
bevor sie im Stream auftauchen.
Und da ist halt definitiv noch eine Bandbreite
zwischen diesen Tools,
die das Ganze irgendwie einfacher machen würden
für die reine Videoproduktion von zu Hause aus.
Ach, du meinst, dass man sagen kann,
wir können jetzt zwar miteinander sprechen,
aber es gibt noch einen weiteren Stream,
der dann live ist und
wir machen schon mal einen Soundcheck quasi.
Wir machen einen Soundcheck, wir
gucken, dass deine Slides
funktionieren, die musst du ja auch irgendwie sharen.
Streamer
zum Beispiel hat, ich glaube, fünf feste
Szenenlayouts.
Das heißt aber, wenn man halt
irgendwie einen Overlay hat mit dem eigenen
Logo oder noch irgendwie den Namen anzeigen
will, dann geht das halt nur an festen
Positionen. Und wenn halt
jemand ziemlich bunte Slides hat,
dann kann es halt einfach sein, dass dein Logo-Overlay
nicht mehr vernünftig aussieht.
Aber du hast halt keine Möglichkeit, es zu
verschieben. In einem Tool wie OBS
oder Lightstream Studio
könnte man halt noch eben hingehen
und das Pixel genau verschieben.
Aber das kann man halt eben nur, wenn man überhaupt
versteht, was ist denn ein ZDL.
Bei den komplexen Tools ein bisschen das Problem ist,
das ist auch ehrlich gesagt das gleiche Problem, das ich hatte, als ich
die zweite Welt für ein CCC gebaut habe.
Du fängst dann mit
einer Umgebung an und
es ist, wie wenn du programmieren lernst.
Also du hast plötzlich einen riesen
Rat da, der mega viel
kann und du denkst dir so,
okay. Und was
mehr dann, also beim Streaming
geht es noch, weil es gibt viele Leute
in meinem Umfeld, die dann sagen, ja hast du das probiert,
hast du das probiert, so Musiker und Filmemacher
und so. Aber bei 2D
Welten war ich dann wirklich an dem Punkt, wo
ich mit dem Entwickler gesprochen habe,
zum Glück war es Open Source und der hatte gerade Zeit
und dann gab es das
Starter Kit, also das hat mich gerettet.
Ich glaube, das ist das,
was wir brauchen für die komplexen Tools,
dass du sagen kannst, okay, hier ist das Tool,
hier sind vernünftige Defaults,
Krypto an dieser Stelle,
also grundsätzlich mal verschlüsseln alles.
Und hier hast du drei Layouts, die kriegst du dazu
und da hast du irgendwie drei Logos
und da kannst du einfach das Logo ersetzen
und das Tool kommt dann damit zurecht,
wenn das größere kleiner ist und so.
Und diese Starter-Kits brauchen wir, glaube ich,
für den ganzen Stack.
Also von...
Quasi diese Entscheidung zwischen, oder dieser Kompromiss zwischen dem Power-Tool, mit dem man das wirklich professionell machen kann, wenn man sehr viel Erfahrung und Übung hat, und dem demokratisierenden Tool, was es vielen Leuten schnell ermöglicht, sowas selber auch zu machen. Das ist ja immer, was UX angeht, eine Gratwanderung.
Genau, und ich glaube, das ist der zweite Teil, den wir überhaupt noch nicht haben,
den habe ich auch noch nie gesehen, ist, dass du dieses klientelbasierte Rollendenken hast
in diesen Starter-Kits, weil selbst wenn du dann OBS hast,
dann schreibst du am Schluss vielleicht so eine kleine Anleitung und sagst einfach,
okay, die Panels unten, die fasst du bitte einfach nicht an.
Du klickst einfach auf die drei Knöpfe in der Reihenfolge und sonst nichts anfassen.
Und da denke ich wieder zurück, wie ich vor meinem Berufseinstieg da im Radiostudio saß
und da waren einfach so, keine Ahnung, 15 Quadratmeter Regler überall und vier Computer
und alles war so, never touch the holy system.
Und ich glaube, das müssen wir ein bisschen vermeiden, indem wir digital halt die Flexibilität haben,
GUI-Komponenten einfach auszublenden für Leute, die es nicht brauchen,
aber halt dann überall so kleine Ethnus haben.
Ein bisschen so wie das neue Blender UI,
wenn ich das so abschließen darf. Kennt ihr das?
Also quasi
so Abstufung,
jetzt mal nur von der Produktions-
und Organisationsseite
zurück zum Streaming. So die Abstufung zwischen
ich mache jetzt
ein kleines Meetup für fünf Leute
zu ich mache eine kleine Konferenz
für 50 Leute zu
und dann jetzt den Advanced-Knopf
und die Sondereinstellung.
Ich mache jetzt eine Konferenz für
2000 Leute und Speaker
Ja, mit Warteläumen und allen Features, die du haben willst.
Und mit Warteläumen.
Und auch Greenscreensverarbeitung kannst du dann dazu buchen,
vielleicht als Extraservice und so.
Dann kannst du irgendwie noch Loops reinbauen,
wo deine Pipeline durchgeht.
Aber am Schluss, ja, es läuft ein bisschen auf Blender raus.
Und die haben auch das UI komplett neu designt.
Also alles versteckt, was du nicht zwingend brauchst.
Und dann musst du halt wieder zurückklicken, was du haben willst.
Insofern war die UI vorher auch echt, naja, also dieser Klassiker,
wegen von Blender kannst du nicht anfassen, weil Links-Klick macht was ganz anderes,
als du denkst.
Das haben sie halt endlich mal ein bisschen zusammengekratzt und richtig gemacht.
Aber ab 2.8 läuft es richtig, richtig gut.
Du musst dann 2.9.1 ausprobieren, weil jetzt haben sie,
2.9 kannst du ja suchen.
Also bei mir ist es Leertaste, keine Ahnung, was das beim Default ist.
Default ist Play-Pause, das ist nutzlos, aber das Suchen ist besser.
Genau, und damit kannst du Aktionen suchen.
Okay, das war mit, glaube ich,
2008 kam das rein, das war schon super.
Was mit 20091 jetzt dazu kommt,
ist, dass du in diesen Side-Panels,
die sind ja auch riesig,
kannst du jetzt Dinge suchen.
Und ich weiß noch, wie das so
katastrophal war, da hast du Dropdown-Menüs
mit 60 Einträgen zum Teil
und du weißt genau, was du willst, aber du bist
trotzdem jedes Mal so,
jetzt kannst du suchen.
Ich bin,
ich möchte allerdings auf der anderen Seite nur noch daran erinnern,
dass es Leute gibt, die sich als Hobby
Flugsimulatoren beibringen. Also man muss auch immer
ein bisschen aufpassen.
Es gibt
eine ganze Menge Leute, die mit
Programmierung nichts am Hut haben, die aber überhaupt kein Problem
haben, sich komplexe Tools beizubringen.
Die Mutter von einem Freund, die aus Gründen
viel zu Hause bleiben muss, schon vor dem Lockdown
und so weiter und so fort, hat sich
auf Anraten ihres Sohnes
mal über Jahre sehr kompetent
GIMP beigebracht und macht damit
sehr, sehr coole Sachen, weil es einfach
für sie da war und
bezahlbar und
eine nette Beschäftigung.
Und die
ist sehr rechnerfern.
Also ich hab
also Zugänglichkeit ist nicht
unbedingt immer nur das
Weglassen von Featuren.
Und GIMP hat halt viele Tutorials,
man hat es ja auch, Blender ist glaube ich auch dadurch
erfolgreich geworden, dass sie halt auch
wirklich, wirklich viele
Beispiele hatten und so weiter.
Also gerade Leute, die Beispiele bauen und darüber wieder reden und so weiter und so fort. Die andere Sache, die ich noch anmerken wollte, und ich glaube, das fällt uns als Open-Source-Community immer ein bisschen auf die Füße.
nutze das mal, um meine Lieblingsstudie dieses Jahr zu
pluggen. Es gab eine Studie im Sommer, die eine sehr interessante
These aufgestellt hat und zwar, der Zugangsweg
in Open Source ist Uniform, Coding
und nichts anderes und das fällt Projekten am Ende
auf die Füße. Ganz stark dadurch, dass es
am Ende im Projektmanagement, im UX und so weiter
fehlt. Also wir können kein User Research machen. Warum?
Weil wir keine Leute haben, die User Research
Erfahrung haben und so weiter und so fort.
Und deswegen, daher kommt, glaube ich, auch so immer das Gefühl,
dass Leute halt sagen, ja, Open Source ist immer ganz cool
und so weiter und so offen und so weiter,
aber es bedient sich einfach nie.
Das ist den Leuten nicht vorzuwerfen, die sie programmieren.
Ich glaube, niemand möchte eine Software
mit einem schlechten Interface schreiben.
Das stimmt, das sind irgendwie,
alle Open Source-Projekte sind fast ausschließlich
von Entwicklern gebaut, wobei zum Beispiel ein AAA-Spiel
welche von der Firma entwickelte Software immer noch Leute für diese Nebenschauplätze
oder für alle anderen wichtigen Sachen mit dazu holt,
die bei Open-Source-Projekten häufig von den Entwicklern selber mitgemacht werden.
Deswegen sieht man wahrscheinlich viele Open-Source-Tools.
Das sind solche Power-Tools oder solche Monster-Anwendungen,
die alles können, aber vielleicht schwer zu bedienen sind.
Ich würde mal einfach behaupten, an AAA-Spielen programmieren relativ wenig Leute.
Das meiste ist Content Creation.
Und die haben entsprechende Tools und entsprechende Tool-Pipelines,
die ihnen da sehr, sehr viel Flexibilität ermöglichen.
Jetzt haben die natürlich, das ist alles hoch spezialisiert,
weil wer sich mal so einen Vortrag darüber angehört hat,
wie zum Beispiel Level-Layout für die PS4 aussieht,
damit man mit dem mangelnden Speicher
und vor allem der richtig, richtig langsamen Festplatte zurechtkommt,
die Probleme haben wir alle nicht.
Das ist auch total schön,
dass wir diese Probleme im Web alle nicht haben.
Aber eine Sache, die ich immer sehr vielen Leuten empfehle an der Stelle,
ist auch mal ein bisschen aus dem eigenen Skop rauszuschauen.
Wir haben jetzt ein bisschen darüber geredet,
so, ah ja, dieses Streaming ist alles neu.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht neu.
Es gibt eine riesen Streaming-Community momentan,
wenn man richtig viel Asche machen möchte auf dieser Erde,
dann wird man Influencer und Streamer.
Und das wird immer so ein bisschen belächelt.
Aber wenn man halt mal so Fragen hat,
ich habe hier noch ein anderes Mikrofon-Setup,
das ich für Workshops und so weiter verwende,
wenn ich Schulungen gebe und so weiter und so fort.
Und wie habe ich mir das zusammengebaut?
Ich habe mir YouTube-Videos von Streamern angeschaut,
die sagen, wie ist denn mein Streaming-Setup?
Wie mache ich denn da, wo tue ich mein Twitch-Widget rein?
Und so weiter und so fort.
Also da ist schon eine ganze Menge Kreativität unterwegs.
Das ist zwar alles in dieser Twitch-Plattform so ein bisschen gefangen
und das ist alles nur auf Single-Video und so weiter ausgerichtet.
Aber es gibt da eine riesige andere Community,
die sich um die Technik überhaupt nicht schert,
aber sich schon sehr, sehr viele Sachen überlegt hat,
was denn die Formate sind und so weiter und so fort.
Wenn man sich zum Beispiel mal Let's Plays zum Beispiel,
ist für mich ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln,
warum sich jemand Let's Plays anschaut.
Ja, wobei es ist kein Buch mit sieben Siegeln.
Ich würde es einfach selbst nicht tun.
Aber zum Beispiel, die haben sehr, sehr früh erkannt,
dass niemand Lust hat, sich irgendwie die ganze Zeit Longplays anzuschauen,
sondern machen halt irgendwie Viertelstunde Zusammenschnitt
von einer Zwei-Stunden-Spiel-Session aus allem
Interessanten, was ihnen dabei passiert ist.
Da ist richtig, richtig viel Produktion hinten dran.
Und
wenn ich dann aber irgendwie so ein bisschen in meine eigenen
Communities reinhorche, wird da viel gelächelt.
Und ich glaub,
nicht zu Recht.
Ja, unrechtigterweise.
Also, Let's Plays angucken,
oder was ich in letzter Zeit immer angefangen hab,
wo jetzt auch ein bisschen die Zeit dafür
fast vorbei ist, ist StarCraft-Tournaments
auf YouTube irgendwie kommentieren,
angucken. Ich mein, am Schluss vom Tag,
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Let's Plays gucken
oder Tournaments gucken und einfach Fußball
im Fernsehen?
Das eine ist viel spannender und das andere
da rennen Leute mit dem Ball rum.
Oder Olympiade.
Aber das ist genau die Sache.
Das ist genau die Sache.
Wir belächeln es teilweise halt, weil wir es uns
nicht vorstellen können, es anzugucken.
Aber man kann halt nicht...
Man sieht halt, wie
erfolgreich es ist.
Südkorea werden da Stadien gefüllt.
Ich out-in-teier erstmal das Let's Play.
Also ich mach das.
Wie gesagt.
Ich belächle die Leute, die Fußball schauen und kann das nicht
verstehen.
Aber wenn es Spaß macht, klar.
Ich gucke beides.
Sorry,
zwei Gründe für mich.
Ich hab kein Geld für starke Hardware
und keine Zeit, um mir so
ein mega komplexes Spiel wie
der Witcher 3 oder so etwas reinzuziehen.
Und Let's Play sind super,
weil du kriegst die Geschichte
und je nachdem,
kriegst du noch.
Den Film kannst du dir
in 50 Jahren noch angucken, aber das Spiel,
da gibt es vielleicht gar keine Plattform mehr von,
deswegen ist es schön, dass es mal jemand auf Video durchgespielt hat.
Ich meine, wir sind da sehr weit
vom Thema abgeglitten,
aber die
Erhaltung von
Online-Rollenspielen oder so ist ein durchaus
wissenschaftliches Problem,
wie man diese Erfahrung bewahrt,
was ja schon große Dinge sind.
Man kann es ja nicht ins Museum stellen.
Das kann man ja wohl,
aber halt nicht für die Online-Spiele, das stimmt.
Also, aber um da zum Thema zurückzukommen,
ich glaube, es wäre super interessant,
sich an der Stelle
da doch mal Recherche zu betreiben
und sich zu überlegen,
was für diesen Teilen können wir dann
als kleine Tools bauen,
die einfach bedienbar sind.
An der Stelle möchte ich auch einfach nochmal erwähnen,
eine der schönen Sachen an Hubs zum Beispiel ist,
dass sie automatisch eine Cloud-Formation-Template mit anbieten,
konfigurierbar, mit dem man das sofort auf Amazon AWS
deployen kann.
Das ist jetzt nicht,
ich würde das jetzt nicht der Zugänglichkeit letzter Schluss,
als der Zugänglichkeit letzter Schluss bezeichnen,
aber gerade das, was Stefan gesagt hat,
ordentliche Defaults und so weiter.
Es ist relativ häufig so,
dass
viele Tools heutzutage
noch so ein bisschen mit dem
ja,
ihr kriegt das schon alles gut selbst zusammenkonfiguriert
Ansatz kommen.
Es ist ja ein Problem, was sehr viel Software hat.
Ja, und auch Sane-Fehlermeldungen
für Konfigurationen.
Also zum Beispiel bei dem einen Tool, was ich benutzt
haben musste, das ist einfach gecrashed. Es hat einfach
geheißen, Config-Fehler.
Am Schluss war es falsch konfigurierter
ein Zertifikat.
Toll.
Aber ich möchte
mal einen hässlichen Namen in den Raum schmeißen,
der vielleicht manche ein bisschen prellt.
Was wäre denn das WordPress der Videokonferenz?
Der Online-Konferenzen?
WordPress hat nämlich,
ja, WordPress hat nämlich,
ich bin immer großer Fan der
WordPress-Community. Man darf nämlich nicht vergessen,
WordPress hat eine Community,
die größer ist, als die fast
aller anderen Programmiersprachen.
Die haben mehr Konferenzen auf dieser
Welt als die meisten großen
Programmiersprachen.
Und die haben einen ganz interessanten Zugang
nämlich zu diesem Punkt. Und ich glaube,
das ist ein Teil des Erfolgs.
Nämlich,
ein ganz klassischer Einstieg in WordPress
ist, ich betreibe eine WordPress-Seite und
ich mache da Dinge und ich benutze die vielen Plugins,
die es gibt und die vielen Widgets, die es gibt.
Und diese
Plugins und Widgets gibt es nur,
weil WordPress eben eine offene Plattform ist.
Aber,
ich kenne mehr als eine Person, die halt
auf WordPress-Meetups gegangen ist
und sich da irgendwie mit den Leuten
ausgetauscht hat und irgendwann gesagt hat,
diese Plugins, die machen
nicht alle so ganz das,
was ich will.
Und plötzlich
nimmst du jemanden zur Seite und sagt, ja,
du könntest ein bisschen
PHP lernen. Und plötzlich hast
du eine Person, die ganz, ganz viel Erfahrung mit
dem Tool hat und mit
Schreiben und Publishing und so weiter
und so fort und eine Webseite betreiben und
vielleicht ein bisschen CSS und was weiß ich sonst.
und die bringt sich Programmieren bei.
Und genau so was könnte man mit Videoplattformen nämlich auch machen.
Und da finde ich so dieses Ding, in dem wir gerade unterwegs sind,
ist halt dieses Widget-Konzept so, ja, cool,
wie schreibe ich mein eigenes Widget oder muss ich ein eigenes Widget schreiben
oder gibt es irgendeinen Widget-Katalog oder sonst was?
Wo finde ich diese Dinge?
Muss ich mir die auf GitHub zusammensuchen oder gibt es irgendwo einen Index?
Kann ich mir die zusammen klicken oder muss ich mir da irgendwie
mehrere Git-Repositories zusammen merchen?
Und das sind alles durchaus wichtige Probleme,
weil diese, also muss ich Coding als Skill können,
um dieses Tool zumindest mal zu starten und zu betreiben.
Und das Wichtigste meiner Erfahrung nach
ist, den Leuten erst mal ein Problem zu lösen.
Und deswegen finde ich diesen Ansatz,
den viele Open-Source-Communities haben,
so du musst hier kommen und mit coden.
So, das ist Contribution, sehe ich gar nicht so.
sondern
wir bedienen,
wer sind eigentlich die User, die wir haben möchten
und ich denke, in diesem Videobereich
ist es sehr wichtig, sich
momentan erstmal auf Leute zu konzentrieren,
die gar nicht so technisch basiert sind,
sondern die momentan ein Problem haben,
nämlich, wir müssen online
irgendwie ein Event veranstalten
und dieses Problem
Wir müssen unsere Schulklasse unterrichten.
Wir müssen unsere Schulklasse unterrichten,
wir müssen unsere Geburtstagsfeier verschieben,
wir müssen unseren Verein
organisieren. Wir müssen
alles das, was momentan nicht mehr geht.
Ja, genau.
Übrigens an der Stelle halt auch
alles im Sportverein schon mal durchgemacht. Ich habe
beim Sportverein dann halt auf Biegen und Brechen
halt Zoom beigebracht. Und warum habe ich ihnen
Zoom beigebracht? Weil es das Tool war,
dass die Leute am wenigsten prellt, weil
sie in die wenigsten Fehlermeldungen laufen.
Also das darf man auch immer nicht
vergessen.
Wenn ich ein neues Tool anfange,
muss ich zuerst mal
einen Wert rausziehen. Ansonsten
ich das sofort. Und ich glaube, dass das
Erfolgskonzept hinter Zoom,
sie sind ganz radikal dabei,
dafür zu sorgen, dass jede
Verbindung auf jeden Fall läuft.
Ich habe mal für einen Telefondiensteanbieter
gearbeitet, da sagte
jemand 95 Prozent, wenn 95 Prozent
der Anrufe durchkommen, dann sei das
okay. Irgendjemand am Tisch sagte mal,
naja, dann verwende ich halt wieder das Telefon, weil
GSM geht halt immer.
Und ich kann es ihm nicht verdenken.
Und
mit diesem
dieser Ansatz ist an dieser Stelle sehr wichtig,
ein sehr user-fokussierter Ansatz.
Aber
trotzdem halt eben mit der Möglichkeit,
Flexibilität anzubieten. Nämlich, wenn
jemand hingeht und sagt, ich möchte bei meinem
Event aber gerne
ein Widget haben, wo die Leute Snake spielen können.
Finde ich wirklich, was Stefan
da gebaut hat, finde ich ein ganz tolles Teil.
Wie kann ich das...
Und weitere Entwicklungsseite.
Ja.
Was uns noch krass unterscheidet von WordPress,
ist die Infrastruktur, die zur Verfügung steht.
Weil WordPress kam ja aus dem Sumpf von Joomla, Drupal und noch was raus,
wo WordPress plötzlich gesagt hat,
okay, wir haben jetzt diese unglaublich vielfältige PHP-Hosting-Landschaft.
Das war ja in der Zeit, dass PHP 5.0 noch ganz neu und shiny war.
Da hat man plötzlich gesagt, schau, wenn du WordPress installieren musst,
dann musst du nicht mit Zips umgehen
und Zeugs rumkopieren,
sondern du kopierst dir eine PHP-Datei
auf deinen Web-Server,
gehst da hin
und dann macht das Tool eigentlich das meiste.
Und ich glaube,
das ist das, was noch fehlt.
Überall gab es
einen Lamp-Stack,
du musstest einfach bloß einmal das Zip runterladen
und irgendwie auf deinen
Server hochladen
und dann bist du auf die Seite hoffentlich als Erster
gegangen und hast als Erster das Admin-Passwort
und dann ausengenästet.
Genau, auf dem Video fehlt uns das,
weil LAMP basierte
Input-Strip auf RPC, also
Anfrage hin, dein Script macht was,
also Antwort zurück.
Für Video fragt man halt ein bisschen mehr.
Und das könnte tatsächlich
die Cloud, weißt du,
so Kubernetes und so, was mag man
jetzt schlecht halten, aber es ist halt das Einzige,
wo du sagen kannst, hier klick mal da
dieses YAML-File
als Link rein
und die Cloud baut sich dann auf.
Ja, die Frage ist halt, wer betreibt die Cloud? Also, ich bin gerade deswegen schon sehr lange weg von der, ich mag die Idee, Tools können selbst gehostet werden, nicht so gerne.
also Self-Hostable Tools,
weil ich denke, dass das den Fokus falsch setzt.
Du bist dann nämlich genau in dem Bereich,
für Video müsstest du ein CDN betreiben
oder zumindest irgendwas, was ähnlich ist einem CDN.
Du musst dich mit ganz vielen Sachen auskennen.
Video kann stark optimiert werden,
indem du zum Beispiel Kernelflex tunest.
Ich habe lange Zeit Videoausspielungen gemacht
und ich habe nie so direkt mit Kernelsachen gearbeitet
wie in dieser Zeit, um irgendwie die letzten Millisekunden
irgendwo noch rauszuholen.
Und
es ist einfach
nicht lohnenswert. Aber es muss doch technisch
möglich sein, dass wir sowas wie
Peertube, was quasi so ein
dezentraler YouTube-Klon ist, wo
über BitTorrent-Technologien
P2P-Videos verteilt werden.
Und sowas wie, wie hieß das?
Popcorn Time, diese wunderbare
Software, die nicht ganz so legal war,
mit der man Filme streamen konnte,
aber auch über BitTorrent.
der die sequenziellen Teile priorisiert hat in dem Video,
dass man sowas vielleicht vereint,
um sowas ohne CDNs auf die Möglichkeit einzustellen.
Potenziell, oder?
Ja, das ist für Real-Time, Video, Audio,
ist es halt sehr, sehr schwierig.
Also wenn du einen Vortrag vor 5000 Leuten halten möchtest,
dann geht das sicherlich.
Da fällt denen nicht auf,
wenn der eine das 10 Sekunden später hört als die andere.
Aber wenn wir jetzt hier sowas wie, ich mache ein Work Adventure mit 15.000 Kongress-Teilnehmern
und die können wie beliebig durch die Gegend laufen und sich zu spontanen Kreisen zusammenschließen
und dann vielleicht auch noch ambientes Audio von allen anderen um sich herum hören,
das kriegst du dezentral.
Ja, du brauchst halt eine cloudartige Infrastruktur, die automatisch hochskaliert
und die Latenzen dann nicht eskalieren.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum Star Citizen immer noch so krass technische Änderungen macht.
Und die werden auch sonst nie fertig.
Aber ich glaube, das ist auch einer der Gründe, weil die haben sich ja ein dynamisches Universum vorgestellt,
wo sie die Kuben, die die Welt simuliert, dynamisch ändern.
Und je nachdem, wie viele Leute zusammentreffen, kommst du dann in möglichst die physisch gleiche Instanz hinein.
Ich habe das Gefühl vor zehn Jahren auf Kickstarter gebackt.
ich schaue da alle zwei Jahre mal rein, wie weit die sind
und es hat sich gefühlt nie was geändert.
Ja gut, aber ich meine,
das ist ein Ding,
das haben ja
verschiedene Online-Spiele
durchaus halbwegs gelöst, also
EVE Online funktioniert ja nach einem ähnlichen Konzept
und läuft jetzt auch schon seit 15 Jahren,
die machen das schon immer so. Also die haben es früher
mit Hardwareblades betrieben, ich gehe mir ja davon
aus, dass sie inzwischen
mit virtuellen
Maschinen arbeiten, aber
was du sagst, stimmt schon.
Und die Frage ist halt, wenn wir,
ich sehe halt den Gewinn
an offener Software an dieser Stelle gerade eben
mehr in der Flexibilität als in der
Ethik.
Das sagen wir mal einfach ganz direkt so.
Die offene und freie
Software gibt mir die Möglichkeit, wenn ich
feststelle, es gibt hier ein Problem an diesem
Scheißding und ich brauche das bis morgen gefixt,
weil jemand unter meinen Attendees hat ein Problem
damit, dann kann ich das machen.
dann habe ich diese Möglichkeit noch.
Es gibt allerdings Dinge in diesem Bereich,
die eben nicht unter diese Sache fallen.
Und da ist halt die Frage,
können wir auf irgendeine Weise nicht die Infrastruktur anbieten?
Diese Infrastruktur muss finanziert werden.
Dann sind wir wieder bei der Frage
Finanzierung offener Infrastrukturen und so weiter.
Habe ich noch einen langen Rant dazu?
Können wir gerne noch mal einen Podcast zu machen?
Ich glaube nämlich, dass ein bisschen dieses Hostess-Doch-Selbst
ein bisschen auch ein Weg da drum ist,
sich genau um dieses Problem rumzumogeln.
An der Stelle nämlich die Frage,
es gibt nämlich Dinge,
die durchaus generisch lösbar sind.
Nämlich das Videostreaming.
Das Stream-In, das Stream-Out.
Das Audio-Streaming,
dafür Plattformen bereitzustellen, ist möglich.
Und dafür das Tooling auch offen zu machen.
Dieses Wissen ist bekannt.
Und das ist auch inzwischen gar nicht mehr so erkannt,
was man da alles machen muss.
Es gibt die Tools dazu.
Es gibt inzwischen auch offene Tools dazu.
Und es gibt, gerade wenn man mal so in Richtung G-Streamer und so weiter schaut,
gibt es eine ganze Menge durchaus industriell verwendete Tools
in diesem Bereich.
Und die Frage, und da gebe ich dir recht, Stefan,
da kommt man halt eben bei dem Problem an.
Ja, WordPress hat viel davon gelebt,
dass es halt überall einen Host gab,
wo ich mir für 5 Euro es klicken kann.
Und solange Index.php die richtige Berechtigung hat,
funktioniert das Ding.
Und der Rest wird konfiguriert übers Webinterface.
und da ist jetzt halt eben die Frage,
wie kann ich
mir auf so einer Plattform
was zusammenbauen, aber halt die
Flexibilität behalten, die meiner Meinung nach
halt gerade das Schöne ist an Events.
Also wenn ich jetzt einfach mal generell über Events
rede und ich glaube, das ist der
Grund, warum
was Leute von
von
On-Site und vor Ort Events
vermissen.
Eben dieses etwas
flexible.
Wir haben zum Beispiel beim Rustfest,
das hatte ich ja das letzte Mal hier schon mal erwähnt,
immer ganz gutes Feedback bekommen,
wenn wir halt gerade mal kein Programm gemacht
haben, sondern einfach mal gesagt haben, hier,
ihr seid in Paris.
Macht was draus.
Geht essen, genau.
Ihr habt hier ein paar nette Leute
gefunden, aber wie können
wir das online anbieten? Und das ist ja auch
gerade der Grund, warum wir zum Beispiel diese
Musik-Acts machen, weil
Musik ist halt eine gewisse shared
Experience.
Also egal, wo ich bin, ich weiß,
eine andere Person irgendwo anders hört gerade
dasselbe und es ist gerade ein Live-Act.
Das heißt, die hören, man hört das auch
nicht wieder, sozusagen. Also man kann
sich irgendwann natürlich das Recording anschauen.
Das ist auch was, was am Anfang, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch,
ich hab den Eindruck,
dieses Jahr sind viele Sachen am Anfang
beim ersten Lockdown,
bei der ersten Welle so ab März, April
passiert und sind danach so ein bisschen
in Vergessenheit geraten. Ich wollte eigentlich gerade auf
Punkt einspringen, aber jetzt, wo du gerade über Musik
Events gemeinsam hören redest,
habt ihr
das auch so wahrgenommen? Ich habe den Eindruck, es gab
am Anfang, ich war zumindest bei einigen
Online-Konzerten,
die wurden dann über YouTube gemacht. Ich weiß,
es gab Acts, die bei mir in der Stadt aufgetreten
wären und das ging dann plötzlich nicht mehr. Und was sie
stattdessen gemacht haben, ist, dass sie dann einfach
in den Studio gegangen sind und da
irgendwie mit drei Kameras das irgendwie nach YouTube
gestreamt haben. Und dann
war halt die
Zuschauer-Experience, dass irgendwie das Publikum
du konntest irgendwie freiwillig per PayPal
irgendwie einen Zähler in den Hut stecken
und dann war die Shared Experience, dass alle
irgendwie im Chat waren und irgendwie mit
einem Klatsch-Emoji zum Schlussapplaus
gegeben haben nach den einzelnen Songs.
Ähnlich wie das
gab es irgendwie am Anfang vom Lockdown
diese Videokonferenz-Partys,
wo
das gleiche Problem hat, was ich gerade beschrieben habe,
dass du diesen Stuhlkreis-Effekt hattest,
weil irgendwie immer bloß einer reden kann, aber irgendwie
vielleicht zwölf Leute da sind. Das ist aber
gefühlt so ein bisschen abgeebbt,
weil da so eine gewisse
Fatigue
eingesetzt hat, dass man da irgendwie
ab April und dann in den Sommerreihen
dann auch man plötzlich keinen Bock mehr auf solche Sachen hatte.
Ich glaube,
das ist zu einem großen Teil
auch einfach ein saisonaler Effekt.
Zum Sommer hin hat sich
die Realität für viele Leute schon wieder
verschoben gehabt. Es war möglich, sich
zu treffen.
Wir hatten einen Top-Sommer.
Man konnte bei 30 Grad am See
Man brauchte diese Dinge nicht mehr.
Man wollte auch bei 30 Grad schlicht schnell greifen
nicht mehr drin sitzen vorm Computer.
Das ist die eine Seite,
wo wahrscheinlich die Zuschauer einfach nicht mehr unbedingt da waren.
Auf der anderen Seite haben sich Clubs, Bars
und andere Event-Locations unglaublich geniale Konzepte überlegt.
Wie können sie denn kleine Events, spontane Events offline veranstalten,
die mit einem begrenzten Pulk funktionieren.
Das habe ich hier gesehen.
Um mich herum hier in den Friedrichshain
gibt es zahlreiche Clubs,
die halt ihre Gärten geöffnet haben
und immer mal wieder Musik hatten.
Die gleichen Clubs haben halt von März bis im März, April und Mai
Online-Streams veranstaltet.
Das heißt, die konnten schlicht und ergreifend
sich verlagern im Sommer.
Das hat dann im Oktober, November,
haben sie auch das Online-Streaming wieder aufgenommen.
Der andere Punkt ist, glaube ich, auch einfach eine Geldfrage.
Im März, April, Mai hatten noch genug Leute auch einfach Geld
auf der hohen Kante, was sie schnell investieren konnten,
um eben sowas aus dem Boden zu stampfen.
Gerade für Musik will man halt ein halbwegs professionelles Setup,
weil wenn du Musik streamst und das mit Knarzen und Knacken
bei den Zuschauern ankommt, dann hört sich das
keiner zwei Stunden an.
Und da ist, glaube ich, dann auch
einfach irgendwann halt
schlicht und ergreifend das Geld alle, um das
weiterhin zu finanzieren und das Ganze
drumherum zu finanzieren, eben wenn
man mit dem gleichen Stream nicht
so viel Geld einnimmt und
im Hintergrund auch irgendwie noch die Location bezahlen
muss, die man ja einfach auch hatte.
Was ich jetzt gemerkt habe
in den letzten
vier, fünf Wochen war, die
Anzahl illegaler Partys,
die ausgehoben wurde, explodiert.
Also es fing, glaube ich, mit Wien an,
die einen Club dicht gemacht haben.
Aber in Linz gibt es jetzt auch Shisha-Bars,
die sind illegal offen.
Und die Schweiz hat natürlich wieder alles übertroffen.
Da haben sich ein paar Senioren
einen Schiffscontainer besorgt
und den eingerichtet als Bar,
irgendwo in ein Waldstück geschleppt
und haben dann eine illegale Bar betrieben
mit 40, 50 Leuten.
die Club Kids sind alt geworden.
Das war ja eine der berühmten Club Kids Partys
in einem Container durch
New York in den 90ern.
Ich möchte mal Ball etwas
hochspielen. Ich glaube
an der Stelle gibt es Gewinner und Verlierer.
Von vielen von den Artists,
die auf der Oxidize
aufgetreten sind, zum Beispiel, haben ganz viele gefragt,
hey, kann ich das Video bitte sofort haben?
weil ich habe schon wieder einen anderen Gig hier.
Also für Künstler, die eh schon Online-Musik gemacht haben
und zum Beispiel auch mit einer visuellen Komponente,
ist momentan der Durchbruch da,
wo sie endlich damit Geld machen können.
Und nicht, also ich weiß nicht,
ob jemand das finale Set vom Rustfest gesehen hat
mit einem Künstler, der mit Farben Visuals gemacht hat.
Also das sah aus wie ein Rendering,
aber eigentlich waren das Farben, die in Topf gemalt wurden
und eine Künstlerin, die dazu Musik gemacht hat.
Das ist ein Riesen-Setup.
Das kriegst du mal, also das von A nach B zu transportieren,
das ist gigantisch.
Und für die ist jetzt plötzlich die Möglichkeit da,
dass Leute auch akzeptieren, dass sie da Gigs kriegen können.
Und die sind nicht billig.
Die andere Sache, die ich mal ansprechen wollte,
weil ich glaube, das haben wir auch gar nicht angesprochen,
ich bin fundamental der Meinung, dass Konferenzen,
selbst wenn On-Site-Konferenzen zurückkommen werden,
werden fundamental anders aussehen.
Und zwar aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Das ist die Frage, die ich noch stellen wollte.
Für jetzt, wo wir beleuchtet haben, wo wir herkommen
und wie es nur dieses Jahr gelaufen ist.
Wie wird es denn nächstes Jahr aussehen?
Genau, jetzt du.
Ich spiele mal Orakel.
Meine Mutter heißt Sybille.
Insofern stamme ich zumindest mal von einem Orakel ab.
die
die große Sache ist,
die Konferenzszene, auch die
Open-Source-Konferenzszene, war die letzten Jahre
ganz schön überdreht. Größer,
besser, teurer.
Ganz, ganz gigantisch und wenn man
sich mal angeschaut hat, jede
Firma wollte unbedingt ihre
große Konferenz haben.
Bis hin zu Konferenzen, die ich
mal bezeichnet gehört habe als
Karneval für
Leute, die ein Startup haben.
gigantisch
und mit gigantischen Budgets
auch einfach
mit
Produktionswerten, die
von nichts zu noch was gehen
und ich habe von einigen von diesen
Konferenzen, habe ich Einblick ins Budget oder weiß mal
zumindest, was die gekostet haben und dann
sind sie ja so, für 600 Leute
holla die Waldfee
und
ich hab ja
sowohl fürs Eurocamp als
und das war die eine Sache, die mir beim Rustfest wichtig war
ist, man kann mit wenig Geld viel
machen, also
und
dann geht man halt vielleicht nicht
irgendwo ins Radialsystem
in Berlin, sondern man
geht halt an die Uni oder
sonst wo
ein billigerer
Es wird so ein bisschen der Reset-Button gedrückt, was
diese exorbitanten Budgets
angeht. Man wird formatmäßig
wieder ein bisschen kleinere Brötchen packen.
Kann ich mir auch vorstellen, weil
viel ist ja auch jetzt finanziell erst mal
dieses Jahr kaputt gegangen. Ich meine, dass man da erst mal
ein bisschen kleiner anfängt. Aber
hast du irgendwie den Eindruck, dass es
Konzepte gibt, die sich jetzt aus diesem
Online-Zwang in die Zukunft
übertragen, dass man sagt, das machen wir
jetzt so, wie wir es vorher gemacht haben, nie wieder,
sondern wir machen es immer so, dass
es auch für Leute, die gar nicht ins Land kommen,
zugänglich, genauso zugänglich ist wie die Leute, die vor Ort
sind oder ähnliche Sachen?
Ich würde es mal andersrum aufziehen. Ich denke, viele
Konzepte sind zusammengebrochen.
Und zwar,
ich kenne relativ viele Leute aus der DevRel-Szene
und da war schon 2019,
wenn man sich DevRelCon London, bei der ich war,
anschaut, war ein ganz großes Thema,
ey, wir verbringen die meiste Zeit
mit Flieger. Und da kam natürlich die
Öko-Thematik mit rein,
da ist gerade Fridays for Future
und so weiter, das war hier da aufgehängt, aber so
ein bisschen Subtext war da drin auch noch,
und seit wir unsere Flüge reduziert haben,
haben unsere DevRails weniger Jetlag
und können sich endlich mal um die Leute kümmern,
um die sie sich eigentlich kümmern sollen,
machen eine E-Mail beantworten oder sonst was.
Leute haben plötzlich festgestellt,
dass ihr YouTube-Kanal
vielleicht ein bisschen Liebe brauchen könnte
und dass das ein richtig großer Kanal sein kann.
Riesige, gigantische Organisationen,
die einen YouTube-Kanal haben,
wo du dir denkst,
ich nutze jetzt den YouTube-Kanal so ein bisschen,
weil egal welche Plattform es ist,
weil man da gut sehen kann,
wie groß die entsprechenden Gruppen da präsent sind.
Und die sind häufig halt einfach sehr,
man merkt, dass viele von diesen Organisationen
sich um die Online-Komponente eigentlich überhaupt keine Gedanken gemacht haben.
Und jetzt gehen die hin und sagen,
okay, wir stampfen jetzt mal eine Online-Konferenz raus
und erreichen damit plötzlich 50.000 Leute im Stream.
Da stellt sich jemand beim Marketing hin und denkt sich,
das Flugbudget von einer halben Million
letztes Jahr?
Was könnten wir damit machen, wenn wir
dafür fünf Leute einstellen und
unseren YouTube-Kanal bearbeiten?
Und
das wird zum
massiven Einbruch und das höre ich auch schon von
allen Leuten, die ich in der Szene kenne.
Einige von den Co-Organisatoren
beim Eurocamp sind ja in die professionelle Szene
gegangen. Verschiedene Firmen
haben komplett, also O'Reilly
hat ihr komplettes Konferenz
den
Konferenzteil, OSCON, also
komplett zugemacht.
Andere Konferenzen
machen jetzt weniger,
aber dafür alle drei Monate und das
online. Und das wird bleiben, weil sie einfach
feststellen, sie erreichen damit Leute, sie machen damit Geld
und sie
brauchen
gar nicht mehr
diesen gigantischen Riss mit
ich muss
eine Venue finden, ich muss mit dir
reden. Es gibt ungemein
viel, viel Arbeit, ungemein viel
Setup-Arbeit und
ich muss ehrlich sagen, der große Fehler,
den wir mit der Oxidize Global, was dann die richtige
Konferenz gemacht haben, war, nicht zu erkennen,
dass wir eigentlich
auch das auch klein
schneiden können und sagen,
vielleicht muss das nicht alles Freitag sein.
Die Rusty Days
im Rust-Bereich haben das ganz toll gemacht.
Die haben gesagt, wir machen
fünf Tage und jeden Abend zwei Talks
und verteilen da unsere Talks drüber.
Es gibt da, plötzlich bin ich auch befreit davon,
von der Location.
Und ganz, ganz viele Leute aus dem Devil-Bereich,
die ich halt kenne, die sagen, mir geht's so gut wie nie.
Ich bin nicht die ganze Zeit am Rumfliegen, ich bin mal wach.
Also wirklich.
Aus dem Jetlag wieder raus.
Ja, ich kenne Leute, die haben ihre Wohnung im Jahr
mal zwei Wochen gesehen.
Also sie sind halt zum Urlaub in ihre Wohnung geflogen sozusagen.
Also diese großen internationalen Anlaufpunkte, diese Sachen, wo Leute aus 50 Ländern hinfliegen und die irgendwie Hunderttausende kosten, was so diese hervorstechenden Lighthouse-Projekte oder Lighthouse-Konferenzen für Leute sind. Da könnte ja vielleicht sogar der Kongress dazu zählen oder irgend sowas wie diese ganz großen Konferenzen.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob ich den Kongress so dazuzählen würde, weil, seien wir ehrlich, viele von diesen Konferenzen waren eigentlich Themenparks und Ego-Trips. Du bist halt auf die Konferenz von folgendem Vendor gegangen und ob das jetzt, also der nächste Kongress wird wahrscheinlich kleiner sein als die vorher, aber der Kongress war noch nie ein Vendor-Prems.
Es gab große Konferenzen, die so der Anlaufpunkt waren,
die hauptsächlich so als Darstellungsplattform genutzt wurden.
Und du meinst, die werden wahrscheinlich zurückgehen.
Und das hat ökologisch auch seine Vorteile,
wenn die Leute nicht mehr hin- und herfliegen.
Nicht nur ökologisch seine Vorteile,
sondern einfach, die Leute sind ja nur nach Outreach aus.
Und plötzlich stellen sie fest, ach, was geht auch ohne.
Unser einer Daryl, der jetzt hier die ganze Zeit zu Hause sitzt
und streamt,
erreicht er viel mehr Leute, als wenn wir
ihn vorher auf irgendeiner Konferenz an eine Booth
gestellt haben und da redet man mit 20,
30 Schluckern jeden Tag.
Das, also
auf der anderen Seite, glaube ich,
Fach-Events werden dadurch wieder wichtiger.
Also wirklich thematische,
vielleicht kleiner,
100, 200, wo die Leute auch wirklich ein
spitzeres Thema zusammen haben.
Nehmen wir mal ein konkretes Beispiel,
so was wie das Rustfest selber.
So eine kleine, Rustfest ist ja eigentlich
weniger eine Konferenz, sondern eher ein großes Meetup.
Ich habe so eine Idee, wohin das gehen könnte nächstes Jahr,
dass man vielleicht das wieder probiert,
mit diesen 24 Stunden über den Planeten verteilt.
Und eine Idee, die ich da hatte, war,
dass man da vielleicht ein, zwei Orte macht pro Kontinent,
wo die Leute sich wirklich treffen,
und dann so Videowände macht,
wo du in eine andere Zeitzone reinschauen kannst,
so dieses gemeinsame Gefühl hast.
Aber ich denke, auch dort wird der Fokus mehr auf Workshops und sich treffen sein und die Vorträge vermutlich eher online oder halt in kleinen Hallen, dass man dann sagt, okay, wir machen nicht 600-Leute-Konferenz, sondern wir machen 150-Leute-Konferenz.
Da schauen einige die Vorträge, aber die meisten treffen sich für die Workshops und für die Impel Days, sondern Impel Days erklären für die Leute, die es nicht kennen.
Das ist, wenn du nach der Konferenz nicht abreißt,
sondern dich zusammen in den Saal setzt.
Ich habe noch ein anderes Beispiel zu nennen.
Die DWC von Apple hat dieses Jahr ja auch dezentral stattgefunden
und komplett gestreamt.
Und der große Unterschied lag darin,
dass man natürlich nicht mehr für 1.000 Dollar versuchen muss,
ein Ticket zu ergattern.
Was auch schon, ich meine, der finanzielle Aufwand auf der einen Seite.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man natürlich auch, wie gesagt, ergattern.
Die waren sehr beliebt und schnell ausverkauft,
bis sie mit der Lotterie angefangen haben.
dann war es halt Zufall, aber die waren definitiv
mehr Andrang da als Leute, die da hinkonnten.
Ich glaube, 5.000, 6.000 Teilnehmer waren
die letzten Jahre da.
Also da ist schon Platz, aber
der Andrang war um einen Faktor 10 oder
sogar höher und noch mehr dahinter.
Und die Qualität,
also zum einen hat jeder, der da teilnehmen
wollte, kostenlos dieses Jahr dann teilnehmen können,
was großartig war.
Ich sehe die WDC auch garantiert
nicht als Ego-Trip von Apple, sondern das ist
eine Veranstaltung, wo neue Technologien vorgestellt
werden und man sich eben weiterbilden kann.
und natürlich fällt der soziale Aspekt ein bisschen flach,
da haben sie versucht, ein bisschen was zu machen,
aber der größte Vorurteil meiner Meinung nach ging dadurch,
dass die Talks nicht mehr auf der Bühne stattfinden,
was natürlich auch ein bisschen mehr,
also der Production Value war um einiges höher,
da stand ein Engineer vor einem schönen Hintergrund
und hat was erzählt und dann haben sie saubere Schnitzel drin gehabt,
also es waren wirklich hochkarätig produzierte Videos,
aber vor allem waren die nicht in eine Konferenzschedule eingetaktet,
Sprich, wenn das Video nur fünf Minuten lang sein hätte können,
dann war das auch nur fünf Minuten lang
und nicht 20 Minuten, um den Slot zu füllen.
Und das war so unglaublich praktisch,
dass man aus dieser Schedule auszubrechen kann,
weil man auch diese Talks, wie wir die C-Talks,
jahrelang noch anschauen würde im Nachhinein.
Wenn man ein Problem hat mit irgendeiner API,
nicht weiß, wie die bestmögliche Nutzung hier ausschaut,
dann wird oftmals verwiesen auf den Talk dazu,
weil da eben von den Leuten, die das entwickelt haben,
vorgestellt wird, wie man das eben auch benutzt.
sind Ressourcen, die man auch im Nachhinein noch anschaut,
sehr oft, häufig.
Und da ist es sehr viel angenehmer,
wenn man da einen 5-Minuten-Talk schaut
statt einen 20-Minuten-Talk. Abgesehen davon, dass es
natürlich auch immer schon die Transkripts von gibt, durch die man
genauso gut durchscrollen kann. Aber das ist
echt was wert, finde ich.
Das ist mir
bei The Mandalorian aufgefallen.
Das muss nicht im Fernsehen gezeigt werden,
irgendwie zwischen zwei anderen Sendungen im Programm eingetaktet
und dementsprechend sind die Folgen mal
20 Minuten lang und mal
50 Minuten lang.
Aber das bloß so am Rand.
Ja, aber das ist ja,
das finde ich eine sehr interessante
Beobachtung,
dass
so langsam
sich das Internet da so ein bisschen durchsetzt,
sozusagen.
Ich war jetzt nie auf der WWDC,
aber das ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass viele von den Vorträgen,
die man jetzt nicht geschaut hat, wenn man nicht auf der Keynote
war, weil die Keynote ist natürlich
ein reines, wir zeigen mal,
was wir hier haben.
Das stimmt, aber der Rest ist halt auch da.
Das muss ein Keynote ja auch sein, aber dass halt viele von den Vorträgen nebendran halt sich sehr im Detail waren, hier diese API und so weiter und so fort. Insofern kann ich, ist für den Wissensgewinn, den man sich davon verspricht, ein Tausender auch gar nicht so viel. Aber trotzdem müssen alle da hinfliegen und so weiter.
Ich glaube, es ist auch ein bisschen Firmenkultur an der Stelle, immer so ein bisschen. Leute, die halt gerade auf einer Konferenz sind, sind halt gerade nicht verfügbar und nicht im Büro und man kann ihnen nicht auf die Schulter touchen.
dadurch, dass wir jetzt eh alle remote sind, müssen wir uns da eh anpassen
und mehr damit zurechtkommen, auch an der Stelle asynchron
zu kommunizieren. Ich glaube, viele Leute lernen da auch gerade viel.
Also im ganz positiven
Sinne, weil sie jetzt mal den Moment haben, sich
mit solchen Sachen zu beschäftigen. Ich habe auch an der Stelle mal kurz wieder mit jemandem geredet,
der gesagt hat, naja, er hat da seine Firma gehabt,
wo die Leute ihn immer belächelt haben, dass er immer geguckt hat, dass auch alles
irgendwie auf dem Online-Storage gespeichert ist
und dass sie ein Videokonferenz-Tool zur Verfügung
haben und so weiter und so fort.
Und alle so, naja, das ist hier irgendwie sein Spielzeug und so weiter.
Und er hat gesagt so, Donnerstag auf Mittwoch,
wir arbeiten jetzt von zu Hause aus.
Im Übrigen, hier ist unser Tool-Stack.
Geschäftsführung.
Für den war das irgendwie ein bisschen Weihnachten.
So zusammen.
Aber in dem...
Genau, aber in dem Moment
sind die Leute halt auch einfach offen für solche Themen.
Und das...
eben auf der MS-Bild halt eben auch aufgefallen,
dass es ganz andere Formate
gibt. Man ist viel weniger
daran gebunden, wen kann ich denn jetzt
... Also, vorher war es ja immer
so, wenn ich einen Speaker haben wollte, dann musste diese Person
nicht für eine halbe Stunde entbehrlich sein, sondern
diese Person musste für drei Tage entbehrlich
sein eigentlich. Sonst lohnt
sich das Fliegen halt nicht.
Und ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich bin,
es ist mir schon auch in meiner eigenen
Konferenz-Javelle-Karriere aufgefallen,
dass ich mal so
ein, zwei Tage auf einer Konferenz hatte, wo ich dann einfach
gesagt habe,
lass bleiben, ich
gehe irgendwo anders hin
und schaue mir Bristol an
und so weiter.
Man hat da ein bisschen Tourismus
mitgetrieben, glaube ich. Und deswegen glaube ich,
es wird halt einfach viel fachorientierter
werden.
Ich gucke so ein bisschen in Richtung
akademische Konferenzen, wo halt auch
andere Programmstile
bestehen.
Zum Beispiel Eintages-Workshops, wo es nur kurze Vorträge gibt und dann Diskussionen, was man daraus machen könnte. Jemand stellt was vor und sagt, im Übrigen, dies ist mein Beitrag hier zu diesem Themengebiet.
Was halt nicht gelöst ist, ist die Homeoffice-Urgücher die ganze Zeit.
Also das ist ein anderes Problem, dass du wirklich sagen kannst,
hey, jetzt habe ich, keine Ahnung, wenn man anfängt, 6, 8, 10 Uhr,
ich arbeite jetzt 6 Stunden und in 6 Stunden bin ich im Büro.
Ich glaube, dieses Problem muss man auch noch lösen,
abgesehen davon, dass man halt den Tourismus nicht mehr hat.
Obwohl ich auch viele Freunde kenne, die dann sagen,
ja, wenn ich schon in Land X fliege,
dann bleibe ich da noch zwei Wochen,
mache gleich Urlaub, Ferien, was auch immer.
Das geht auch.
Also ich würde ihm auch zustimmen,
ich würde diesem Tourismus jetzt nicht so schlecht reden.
Das ist ja auch ein Grund,
warum es viele Leute gerne machen
und ich würde ihn auch sehr vermissen.
Ich spiele so ein bisschen in diese Homeoffice-Kerbe auch mit rein.
Es funktioniert alles
und es wird durchaus professionalisiert dadurch,
dass wir es online machen.
Es wird auch sehr gestreamlined,
aber genauso wie Online-Konferenzen
ist es auch beim Homeoffice so,
dass wir es halt auf die Funktionalitäten begrenzen,
die Zusammenarbeit.
Was zum Beispiel nicht funktioniert,
wenn du Homeoffice machst,
ist, dass du dich mit deinen Kollegen anfreundest,
dass du zwischendurch in einer Kaffeeküche miteinander redest.
Und bei Konferenzen funktioniert es nicht,
dass du in der Stadt, wo du sonst nicht bist,
wo du zum ersten Mal bist,
Paris, Barcelona, mit dem einen
Konferenzteilnehmer, den du bereits
nur über GitHub kennst, der aber zufällig
aus der Stadt kommt, dass du von dem so ein bisschen die Stadt gezeigt
bekommst. Das sind diese Sachen,
kann man die abbilden? Wird das
wiederkommen oder ist das jetzt für die nächsten paar
Jahre erstmal Geschichte, bis ich
vielleicht doch wieder
lokale Konferenzen,
wo die Leute hinreisen, etablieren?
Wird das vielleicht nie wieder etabliert
werden, weil wir es nicht mehr brauchen, weil alles
online geht? Geht da nicht auch ein bisschen
Kultur bei verloren vielleicht, ist so meine Befürchtung.
Ich denke nicht.
Also einmal
habe ich, ich habe
mein Open-Source-Engagement immer
dazu genutzt, muss ich ehrlich sein,
um auch zu sagen,
hey, ich habe in jeder Stadt auf dieser Welt
einen Couch, sozusagen.
Ich reise gerne und das ist eine
coole
Gelegenheit,
Leute kennenzulernen.
Und wenn ich dann halt mal auf einer Konferenz war,
habe ich mir halt zwei Tage mehr Zeit genommen.
Ich glaube, man muss sehr stark unterscheiden
zwischen Leuten, die einfach mal auf eine Konferenz
gehen.
Die
gehen normalerweise im Jahr auch bei physischen Konferenzen
auf eine, maximal
zwei Konferenzen.
Insbesondere Leute mit Familie, für die ist immer
gleich ein Wochenende weg oder ein Teil der Woche
und so weiter und so fort. Das ist ein substanzieller
Chunkzeit.
Deswegen am Rande war ich auch immer der Meinung,
das macht überhaupt, also halte Talks mehrfach,
weil 90% der Audience
hat sie eh noch nicht gesehen.
und dann gibt es diesen,
dann gibt es dieses Konferenz-Chatset
und ich glaube, das wird sich ein kleines bisschen auflösen
und das finde ich gut.
Es gibt Communities,
in denen weiß ich eigentlich
bevor eine Konferenz, oder wusste,
muss ich jetzt korrekterweise sagen,
bevor eine Konferenz angekündigt wurde,
eigentlich schon, wer spricht.
Weil es da eigentlich so
eine Gruppe von Leuten gab,
bei denen deren Job es war,
eine bestimmte Firma zu repräsentieren
und die konnten auf jede Konferenz gehen
Die haben es einfach komplett bezahlt bekommen.
Und
ich habe das auch eine Weile
für meine Firmen gemacht, im Prinzip,
diesen Konferenz-Travel. Und ich habe
dieses Jahr in
Denver festgestellt, war ich in Denver und dachte
so, da kannst du mal zwei Tage, das ist ein bisschen länger,
da kannst du mal am Wochenende in die Berge. Und dabei habe ich
festgestellt, ich war in den USA bisher
eigentlich nur in Flughäfen und
Konferenzzentren gewesen.
Insofern ist die Frage,
habe ich Seattle mal besucht oder habe ich
nur mal den Seattleer Flughafen besucht?
und das ist kein unüblicher Fall
und ich glaube, diese
Kultur wird sich ändern und ehrlich gesagt,
ich werde sie auch nicht vermissen, weil eine Sache,
die ich am Rustfest ganz arg genossen habe
dieses Jahr ist, ich bin jetzt seit sieben Jahren
in der Rust-Community unterwegs
und ich kannte eine Person, die da gesprochen
hat und das ist richtig cool.
Ich habe so viele neue Leute kennengelernt,
die ganz interessante Vorträge gehalten haben,
sehr roh, sehr neu.
Leute, die ihre ersten Vorträge gehalten haben,
ich liebe sowas.
Ich mag polierte Vorträge eigentlich gar nicht so stark,
weil das Problem an den hochpolierten Vorträgen ist,
mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit habe ich das Thema schon mal irgendwo gesehen.
Mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit kenne ich die Person auch schon
und weiß so grob, was sie machen,
als jemand, der einfach viel unterwegs ist in dieser Community.
Ich habe so viele Einblicke bekommen,
was in Japan passiert, was in Südamerika passiert,
über das Was-Fest,
einer der
besten Vorträge darüber gehalten hat,
warum Firmen sich eigentlich in der
Community engagieren sollten, aus denen sie
Ressourcen ziehen.
Und zwar mit einem super guten Argument.
Als selbst eigene Versicherung.
Also
nicht irgendwie aus,
weil das irgendwie
nett oder sonst was ist, sondern schlicht
und einfach gesagt hat, wenn wir auf diese
Technik setzen, dann
ist es wichtig, dass wir zu dem Grundrauschen beitragen,
aus dem wir ja selbst wieder Nutzen ziehen,
weil das ein Amplifizierer ist.
Habe ich so klar noch nie gehört, kannte die Person nicht.
Und das einfach mal nicht so aus dem eigenen Zirkel zu hören.
Und das, finde ich, ist eine Sache, die ich denke,
gut ist, dass sie nicht mehr da ist.
Und das, ich habe da auch noch ein ganz kleines bisschen aufzuholen, vor einem Jahr, zwei Jahren ein Coaching für Speaker gesehen, wo die dieses Coaching gemacht hat, direkt gesagt hat, das ist eine sehr amerikanische Sicht der Dinge oder, ja, nee, eigentlich nicht, direkt gesagt hat, ja, eigentlich geht es nur um die Unterhaltung.
Also die Leute sollen irgendwie so ein bisschen Connection durch haben
und eigentlich geht es nur um Unterhaltung und dann redet er halt
ein bisschen über Docker.
Schon ein bisschen krass.
Da kann ich dir 50 Vorträge nennen,
die ich in den letzten Jahren gesehen habe, die genau in diese
Kategorie fallen.
Und da habe ich lieber jemanden, der mit einem
eher mauren Vortragsstil was vorstellt,
was ich noch nie gesehen habe.
Unter Umständen irgendwas, was ich auch
mich auch gar nicht so
interessiert.
Es gibt ja auch Leute, die, wenn du die auf YouTube raus
suchst, dann findest du denselben Vortrag
von denen halt fünfmal aus
unterschiedlichen Städten und da ist
halt die Frage, was ist der Informationsgehalt
dieses konkreten Vortrags
wirklich? Da fehlt so die Marke
hier, das ist wahrscheinlich ab
Minute 23 oder irgend sowas.
Aber
das war ja, was Florian
eben erwähnt hat.
Für Konferenzen, die tatsächlich
in person stattfanden, war das ja okay,
wenn man einen Talk hat,
der schon bei drei
Konferenzen gegeben wurde, eben weil die
Audience, weil
die Main Audience waren, die, die
vor Ort sind und dass es hinterher frei verfügbar
ist, ist ein Zusatzbonus,
aber nicht die
Main Audience und die vor Ort
Leute kannten den Vortrag, in dem Fall
wahrscheinlich zu 90% eben noch nicht.
Ich glaube, das wird sich halt
ändern, wenn es halt alles
dahin, wenn vieles dahin geht, dass
mehr Material sofort verfügbar ist,
weil dann lohnt es sich halt
nicht den gleichen voraufgenommenen
Vortrag bei drei verschiedenen Konferenzen
zu streamen.
Ich würde aber auch gerne
noch einmal kurz ein bisschen orakeln,
gerade aus der Sicht
des REST Fests.
Das ist doch vielleicht so als den,
weil wir jetzt die Zwei-Stunden-Marke
wirklich auch gerissen haben, vielleicht so als
Abschlusssequenz dieser
Folge machen. Was denkt ihr denn?
Und Jan-Erik,
fang bitte an.
Wie geht's 2021
oder 2022 weiter.
Ja, also ich
spreche hier explizit alles.
Alles ist Orakel. Nichts davon
ist in Stein gemeißelt oder
festgelegt oder auch nur
anderen Leuten des Rustfest-Teams bekannt.
Ich glaube,
in 2021
wird es noch
ein Online-Rustfest geben.
Ich hoffe, dass es ein anderes
Format wird als das,
was wir hatten. Ich will nicht sagen, dass es
Aber ich glaube, wie wir jetzt zwei Stunden lang geredet haben, es gibt durchaus noch Optimierungspotenzial auf jeder Seite einer solchen Konferenz.
Ich wünsche mir und ich glaube auch daran, dass wir danach in Zukunft Wege finden, dass Konferenzen wieder stattfinden können, auch vor Ort.
Ich sehe das auch wie Florian, dass wir da wahrscheinlich fachspezifischere, kleinere Events machen werden können. Aber was ich mir ganz stark erhoffe, ist, dass wir diesen Online-Gedanken nicht ganz verlieren, dass wir uns Konzepte überlegen, die vielleicht hybrid funktionieren.
Wir haben diese Konzepte noch nicht und ich glaube, bislang hat auch keiner Vorstellung, wie das tatsächlich vernünftig funktionieren kann, aber ich bin mir sicher, dass wir in den nächsten zwei bis fünf Jahren Varianten finden, um eben so hybride Events tatsächlich für alle Beteiligten irgendwie zugänglich zu machen.
Soll ich weiter orakelen? Ich habe ja schon ein bisschen.
Ja, gerne.
Also die Idee mit den Video-Wänden, habe ich ja schon gesagt, könnte man vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter spinnen, das wird aber sicher nicht in den nächsten fünf Jahren passiert mit so Hologrammen wie dem neuesten Star Trek, wo die Räume so ineinander verschmelzen.
Das wäre sehr spannend, dass es in der nächsten Zeit Hologramme gibt, sowas in die Richtung.
Ich denke, jetzt mal vom Event weg, weil für mich die Unterscheidung zwischen Meetup, wo man ein bis drei, vielleicht fünf Vorträge hat oder so Lightning Talk Nachmittag, wo man zwei Stunden, einfach fünf Minuten Slots hat und zu konferenzartigen Gebilden, ist der technische Unterschied nicht mehr so groß.
Es geht vor allem um Organisation. Und was ich mir als große Herausforderung feststelle, ist, die bestehenden Organisatoren lernen jetzt extrem viel dazu. Aber was halt fehlt, ist sozusagen die neuen Leute. Und ich denke, das wird ein signifikanter Teil werden, wo wir als Organisatoren uns sagen müssen, okay, ich will das nicht mehr ewig machen. Wie kriege ich neue Leute dazu?
Und da kann es sich durchaus auszahlen, vielleicht zu sagen, okay, ich mache regelmäßigere, kleinere Dinge.
Vielleicht einmal pro Woche, wenn es ganz hoch kommt oder sonst einmal pro Monat, aber planbar und dann halt auch explizit so einen Raum schaffen und sagen, okay, das war jetzt das Thema vom Abend mit Vortrag und allem.
Und ich bin jetzt von der Organisation da und ich versuche jetzt neue Projekte zu starten und zu verknüpfen, weil ich weiß nicht, ob ich mit den aktuellen Konferenzen sozusagen den Mut und ein bisschen die Dreistigkeit aufgebracht hätte, einfach zu, ich glaube es war Hoverbear, einfach hinzulaufen und sagen, hey, dieses Rustfest in Berlin, das ist geil.
Ich will das auch in Zürich machen, aber ich brauche ein Jahr dafür und ich suche mir jetzt noch Leute hier an der Konferenz, die das mitziehen wollen.
Ich glaube, dieser Teil, der fehlt noch.
Das ist auch nicht so groß auf dem Schirm, aber das glaube ich, müssen wir uns noch anschauen.
Und der Rest, Tools kommen, Geld kann man auftreiben, es kommt.
Dem kann ich mich nur anschließen. Das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum ich beim Rustfest zurückgezogen habe, weil meine Zeit da einfach vorbei war, meine Ideen aus und dann ist es ganz gut, wenn man sich da ein bisschen zurückzieht.
Einfach damit andere Leute da auch, ich sag's ganz ehrlich, was Fast Global, so wie es stattgefunden hätte, hätte ich weder die Kapazität noch die Kraft noch die Ideen dazu gehabt, an verschiedenen Stellen so radikal zu sein, wie es war und so roh, wie es war.
Die andere Sache, auf die ich sehr hoffe, ist, es gibt momentan einen sehr starken Drift in der Open-Source-Community, doch verschiedene Themen, die wir lange liegen haben lassen, auch mal wieder aufzugreifen.
Und ich hoffe und ich sehe das auch ein bisschen, dass es da auch eine neue Generation von Leuten gibt, die eben ganz aggressiv sagen, wir möchten auch zum Beispiel Infrastruktur an dieser Stelle bereitstellen, sagen, die könnt ihr nutzen und wir kümmern uns mal darum, dass es auch das Geld gibt, das hier betrieben werden kann.
Das fände ich super interessant an der Stelle. Und dann bleibt aber am Ende trotzdem noch, dass ich denke, da viel Software zu schreiben ist. Und ich finde es einen super interessanten Punkt, weil das Software ist, die fundamental mit Leuten interagiert, mit großen Gruppen und mit dem, was große Gruppen machen wollen und was das ausmacht.
und ich finde, das sind wenig beackertes Feld
und
ich hoffe, dass das, was wir bei
Offline-Konferenzen,
wie man es immer so nennt, gesehen haben,
nämlich, dass die Open-Source-Community da auch
durchaus innovativ ist, weil sie eben mehr
Freiheiten hat. Wir können einfach
eine Konferenz hinstellen,
wo an der Stelle
das CSS noch nicht so passt und wo es auch irgendwie
zwischendurch mal abstürzt und so weiter und so fort.
Die entsprechenden Personen,
die anwesend sind, sind da
eigentlich relativ cool mit.
und
an der Stelle das nutzen, um
auch mal wieder ein paar
Zirkel, um die
großen Konferenzen zu laufen, an der
Stelle und
ich hab mal so ein bisschen Vergleich
gezogen, so was den Rust Conf,
Rustfest und Oxidize Conf denn so
an Viewern hatten, man sieht das ja
alles bei den YouTube Livestreams im Gegensatz
zu einigen großen kommerziellen Konferenzen
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, wir stehen
da gar nicht so schlecht da
und
das ist ein super interessantes Problem und deswegen kann ich einfach nur sagen, wenn jemand Lust hat, daran zu bauen, dann mach das und zwar auch offen im Sinne von nutzbar für Leute, die sich einfach nur online treffen wollen.
Und mit weniger Interesse da sind.
Kein Interesse an der Technik haben.
Das finde ich einen ganz wichtigen Punkt.
Ja, das ist so mein Schlussplädoyer.
Ich freue mich auch drauf, was das kommende Jahr so zu bieten hat.
Ich meine, der Druck dazu, der uns zum aktuellen Status quo geführt hat,
der wird uns dann noch eine ganze Weile begleiten.
Wenn wir mit der Impfgeschwindigkeit weitermachen,
mit der wir jetzt losgelegt haben,
dann würden wir es nicht schaffen, im nächsten Jahr uns alle zu impfen.
Ich vermute mal, es wird ein bisschen schneller werden und wir werden irgendwann im Herbst gleich drankommen.
Also das würde ich so, wie gesagt, eine ganze Weile begleiten, das Aktuelle beizubehalten.
Und ich mag auch die Bequemlichkeit sehr, aus meinem Wohnzimmer heraus Sachen beiwohnen zu können
und die Möglichkeit haben, verschiedene Sachen beiwohnen zu können, bei denen ich sonst noch wie war.
Vielleicht schaue ich mir nächstes Jahr mal ein Wastfest an, da war ich bisher auch noch nicht.
Und andere Sachen in der Richtung.
Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es natürlich auch Sachen, die davon leben. Der Kongress ist nicht derselbe Kongress, ohne dass man da ist. Die Talks sind das eine, die waren auch schon immer großartig, aber die hat man halt wenig davon angeschaut. Die hat man aus dem ersten Kongress angeschaut, wenn man da war. Und danach wurden es immer weniger und vielleicht noch ein paar Highlights mitgenommen.
Aber ansonsten ist man da gewesen, um andere Leute zu treffen und sich zwischen blinkende Lichter zu setzen, eine Waffel zu essen oder den Late-Night-Crab und da so einen Tee zu trinken und eine Mate zu trinken und Spaß zu haben. Und das lässt sich nicht so wirklich transferieren, habe ich das Gefühl.
Es geht natürlich mit besseren Tools immer mehr und mehr, aber das ist nicht das gleiche Feeling, was sich da aufbaut. Und ich freue mich darauf, bei anderen Sachen das zu sehen. Ich freue mich darauf, den Kongress irgendwann wieder besuchen zu können. Jetzt ist er schon endlich in meine Nähe gezogen in Leipzig. Dann kann es auch gerne noch eine Weile da bleiben. Da freue ich mich drauf. Aber ich kann sie eigentlich nur bessern vom aktuellen Punkt aus. Die Tools werden besser, Corona ist irgendwann vorbei. Das wird schon.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass 2020 war so das Jahr, wo wir mal alles anders machen mussten und dementsprechend sehr viel Porzellan, was auch keiner mehr gebraucht hat, endlich zerschlagen wurde.
Und es war ein sehr großer Innovationsdruck da, der glücklicherweise auch so einige oder andere Blüten geschlagen hat.
Und ich freue mich sehr drauf, was in den nächsten Jahren so konferenzmäßig möglich sein wird.
Wir sehen ja bereits jetzt sehr viele kreative Lösungen in dem Bereich.
Und wie Kylian gerade gemeint hat, es wird wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Monate so weitergehen.
Dementsprechend bin ich sehr gespannt darauf, was als nächstes für coole Tools und Lösungen aus dem Boden schießen.
Die Szene ist ja sehr kreativ.
Ich hoffe, dass wir vor allem diesen professionellen oder professionalisierten Bereich nicht zu sehr in den Vordergrund stellen. Was du gerade gesagt hast, Florian, dass das alles sehr viel mehr fachspezifisch ist oder was ich bei Homeoffice immer anprangere, dass man sich eigentlich nur noch über Arbeit unterhält, dass man sich bei der Konferenz auch nur noch über die Vortragsthemen unterhält.
Also dieses, ich wünsche mir eigentlich, dass dieser zwischenmenschliche Teil und das Kennenlernen und das wirklich, dann sind es halt bloß 500 Leute am Ort und ich habe mich aber zum Schluss mit 30 unterhalten und fünf neue Freunde gemacht bei der Konferenz oder so.
Also ich wünsche mir, dass dieser Aspekt eventuell, oder dass dieser Aspekt nicht mit ausstirbt, wenn wir die gesamten Konferenzen vielleicht anders organisieren in der nächsten Zeit.
Ich glaube, dann muss ich da doch noch ein ganz kleines bisschen nachbessern.
Ich muss sich nachher auch noch, bevor da Missverständnisse auftreten.
Ich denke, mit dieser Fachbezogenheit, ich habe extra...
Und da war er eingefroren.
Oh nein.
Nein.
Und weil wir uns an dieser Stelle auf der Aufnahme nicht gegenseitig gehört haben,
hier der Teil, den Florian dann weitergesagt hat.
Und danach geht es fließend weiter.
Ich denke, mit dieser Fachbezogenheit, ich habe extra den Begriff professionell ein bisschen vermieden.
Ich denke, wir gehen wieder mehr zum Kern, warum wir uns eigentlich treffen.
Wir treffen uns wegen dieser Technik, wir treffen uns wegen diesem Thema
und wir halten Vorträge darüber, die dafür sorgen,
dass wir das Thema, an dem wir arbeiten, besser verstehen
oder wir machen einen Workshop, in dem wir gemeinsam
zum Beispiel ein bestimmtes Thema voranbringen.
Das meine ich mit
Fachbezogenheit.
Vielleicht möchte Stefan kurz dazwischen.
Oh, ist er wieder da?
Ich probiere es mal.
Er ist auch im Kaster grau geworden.
Ja, ich schreibe ihm mal.
Stefan redet dazwischen.
Genau, was ich vorhin vergessen habe, sind eigentlich zwei so extrem einfache Dinge.
Der Stickertausch, der fehlt ein bisschen und dass man was aufhängen kann.
Die Sticker.
Also Stickertausch haben wir beim CTC jetzt so gemacht, dass die lokalen Gruppen eine Postadresse gegeben haben
und dann schickst du einen Brief hin und sagst, wie viel, ich glaube Kilo oder Gramm war es,
wie viel du zurückhaben möchtest.
Drei Kilo Sticker.
Wie sticken Sie dann das?
In Stickern, ja.
Ich habe jetzt dieses Jahr bewusst nicht mitgemacht,
weil ich gedacht habe, ich will nicht wieder.
Das letzte Mal, als ich das gemacht habe,
habe ich so einen Sack bekommen.
Sein 17 Liter Sack Cybersticker.
Ich habe über 1000 Stück immer noch.
Und ich verschenke die wirklich so.
Die Wand hinter sich sieht aber gar nicht so vollgeklebt
mit Cyberstickern aus.
Das geht noch ein bisschen.
Also jetzt entschuldigt das Rascheln,
aber hier ist der Sack.
Den kann man jetzt leider nicht sehen.
Ich wollte eigentlich...
Ich gebe euch dann hinterher meine Postanschrift.
Ja, ich möchte noch ein paar von sichern.
Ja, das mache ich gerne.
Wir haben die Einsende-Deadline leider verpasst,
weil wir unsere Sticker bestellen mussten.
Aber ich hatte einen kurzen
Verbindungsabbruch.
Was ich noch sagen wollte,
zum letzten Satz.
Das Showmanship, das vermisse ich halt nicht.
Also ich glaube, die letzten zehn Jahre
durchaus, also über die letzten zehn Jahre
sind es ganz, ganz viel
Präsentation, Showmanship,
und so weiter hat stattgefunden, was das für
gerade
Community Organizer
auch wirklich schwer gemacht hat,
überhaupt noch mit
dem Niveau mitzuhalten.
Und das vermisse ich überhaupt nicht.
Und wenn das nicht wiederkommt, dann werde ich auch
kein traurigerer Mensch sein,
sondern mich eben, genauso wie
Kilian das sagt, mit Leuten treffen, um mich
über Rust zu unterhalten, über Technik, über
Probleme offener Software und so weiter und so fort
und mich mal zusammenzusetzen und nach Lösungen zu
suchen und so weiter und so fort. Das meine ich mit
Fachlichkeit und natürlich
auch mit den Leuten auch ein Bier zu trinken.
Das geht digital irgendwie nicht so
gut.
Stimmt, also
dass diese Kultur von den
Speakern, die einfach überall gefragt sind
und die Main Acts
sind, die aber irgendwie von
den anderen nicht getoppt werden oder nicht erreicht werden,
dass das so ein bisschen weggeht.
Ja, das kann ich
sehr gut verstehen.
Gut, wir
einen sehr langen Podcast
gemacht diesmal. Wir sind jetzt
doch schon bei gut zweieinhalb Stunden.
Und wir haben noch gar nicht über Chats gesprochen.
Eigentlich
wollten wir über Chats reden am Anfang.
Lass uns das doch eventuell
zu Tagen.
Das beziehen wir definitiv nochmal nach.
Lass ich mir nicht nehmen, das nochmal anzuschneiden
in einer indizierten Folge.
Wir haben ja jetzt gesehen, wie das mit dem
verteilten Podcast-Aufnehmen funktioniert.
Auch mit Leuten, die sich keinen
Studio-Link installiert haben.
Dementsprechend bin ich da
durchaus zuversichtlich, dass wir das
vielleicht sogar in dieser Runde nochmal
ähnlich hinkriegen können. Das würde mich auf jeden Fall sehr
freuen.
Sehr schön. So, jetzt haben wir
zwei Stunden, zweieinhalb Stunden erreicht.
Wir haben normalerweise eine
PIX-Sektion, aber ich würde
die jetzt der... Vielleicht können wir sie ja nicht ganz kurz
an der Ende noch schieben, wie das
ein kurzes, tolles Projekt
noch so in zwei Sätzen vorstellt.
Ja, machen wir das. Dann fängt
doch der Jan-Erik einfach mal an.
Okay, dann
ich habe zwei Picks.
Als allererstes, wenn ihr noch immer Lust
habt, euch Talks über
Rust anzuhören, dann guckt in die
Rustfest-Playlist rein.
Wenn ihr keine Lust auf Tech habt,
da sind auch sieben Artist-
Recordings drin, das heißt, ihr könnt
auch einfach vier Stunden lang Musik
hören, auch beim Rustfest.
Alles auf unserem YouTube-Channel oder
auf unserer Webseite, wird also auch verlinkt.
Und als kleines Tool bin ich vor kurzem auf Tab RS gestoßen,
ein kleiner Terminal-Multiplexer, wenn ihr T-Marks oder Screen kennt.
Das ist so eine Minimal-Variante davon.
Immer diese Rust-Rewrites, aber finde ich cool.
Es ist ja kein Rewrite, es ist ein neues Konzept, aber...
FD ist auch ein neues Konzept, aber...
Ich finde es auch cool, Ripgap ist auch super cool.
Sorry, Kylian, das ist leider die Bubble.
Ist schon richtig, ist schon richtig. Ich mache mal direkt weiter.
Wenn ihr mir schon einen sehr Rust-lastigen
Postcast hier gemacht habt und ich eher
nicht so der Rust-Station bin,
habe ich mir mal ein Zwift-Projekt rausgezogen, um ein bisschen
Kontra zu geben. Und zwar ist
das ein Projekt namens Memes.
Das ist ein Spiel, was man
auf einer Webseite spielt. Mir geht es gar nicht
so sehr um das Spiel an sich. Das ist so ein Klon von
Know Your Meme, wo man so Memes spielt und
versucht, lustige Matches zu machen. Mir geht es
eher darum, dass das Ding eine Zwift-Server
Komponente hat, im Backend-Swift,
aber auch im Frontend-Swift.
Und so eine schöne Beispielanwendung ist für ein Projekt,
welches auf der Frontend-Seite komplett mit WebAssembly und Swift läuft.
Das müssen wir uns mal genauer anschauen, Hendrik.
Und vor allem auch mit einem tollen Tool namens Tokamak,
beziehungsweise Tokamak UI,
welches eine Swift-UI-ähnliche, beziehungsweise fast identische,
zintags nutzt, um UI im Frontend zu zeichnen.
Finde ich super cool.
Und es ist von Matthias, Friend of the Show.
Hi, Matthias.
Soll ich das wieder zurückführen nach Rust?
Na klar.
Also wir machen einen sanften Einstieg.
Das Spiel, das vorhin erwähnt wurde,
das Multiplayer Snake,
ihr könnt das spielen.
Soll ich die URL sagen oder blenden wir die einfach ein?
Die tun wir in die Show Notes.
Ja, schick's einfach in den Chat.
Also MPS könnt ihr das
runterladen, hacken, laufen lassen.
Source Code ist öffentlich.
Es gibt inzwischen auch einen Vortrag dazu
für mehrere Teile.
Das nächste
Projekt extrem rustig ist
der Thread Pool. Da bin ich der Maintainer.
es gibt
ein neuer API, wo
ich versuche mit dem Rust
2018 den Stil
zu ändern
aber ja, das Threadpool 2.0
ein grösseres Thema
und zum Schluss dann noch ColorBlinder
das
Projekt, das ich gemacht habe, weil
ich wollte für
verschiedene Webseiten, auch Rustfest
wollte ich das so optimieren, dass
die UIs ein bisschen lesbar
sind, wenn man ein bisschen Farbschwäche
hat zum Beispiel oder wenn man
komplett farbenblind ist.
Es gibt verschiedene Simulatoren dazu
und inzwischen auch eine in GTK
geschriebene GUI.
Allerdings muss ich bei der GUI sagen,
läuft nur auf Linux im Moment.
Aber ja, wenn,
du darfst es gerne kompilieren auf Mac oder Windows
und mir dann Pull Request schicken.
Source Code ist auch öffentlich.
Vorteil von der QE ist, sie arbeitet mit einem kontinuierlichen Screenshot.
Also es nimmt, glaube ich, alle zwei Sekunden standardmäßig einen Screenshot
und verarbeitet entlang die Filter und dann siehst du dein Spiel, Webseite, Dokument,
was auch immer, immer mit den verschiedenen Chromas.
Nicht schlecht.
Ich hatte neulich, glaube ich, sowas ähnliches als Teil der Chrome DevTools gesehen,
dass man das durch seine eigene Webseite
durch unterschiedliche Filter durchjagen kann.
Ich glaube, Firefox kann es auch inzwischen.
Aber es geht halt nur für die Webseiten.
Wenn du ein anderes Tool hast
oder Grafiken editierst,
irgendwie mit Photoshop, Gimp, Krita, Blender.
Es kann auch keine Videos,
aber ich nehme gerne Requests.
Videos sind auch noch viele Bilder.
Ja.
Sehr gut.
Ja. Vielen, vielen lieben Dank. Ich mache mal einen kleinen zwischendurch, weil ich mich sonst fast raushalten wollte. Ich hatte noch ein Follow-up zu unserer letzten Folge, wo wir über Edgard geredet hatten und da ich bei mir einen Home Assistant stehen habe, habe ich festgestellt, eigentlich kann man den Home Assistant auf dem Raspberry Pi sehr gut für viele dieser kleinen Zusatzdinger benutzen, denn viele Sachen, für die man sich normalerweise in den Raspberry Pi konfigurieren und die noch auf dem Stapel der anderen Raspberry Pis, die bei einem zu Hause neben dem Bruder liegen, hinlegen,
würde, kann man sich auch einfach als Add-on
in Home Assistant installieren und somit ist dein
Home Assistant, mit dem du dein Licht an- und ausmachst,
auch das Gerät, was dein
Netzwerk auf
Werbung filtert.
Ich packe den Link in die Show Notes dazu.
Oder eigentlich einfach mal Home Assistant ausprobieren
und dann Add-Guard anklicken.
Und Florian?
Ja, ich picke mal schnell
spontan. Ich
schaue mal, dass ich später noch einen Link
in die Show Notes packe für Tools,
denen man sich Color Gradients
aussuchen kann, die für farbenblinde
Menschen funktionieren.
Also gerade
so Sachen von kalt nach warm, also für
Graphen und so weiter und so fort.
Ja,
meine Picks,
ich, einmal ein Projekt, an dem ich selbst beteiligt
bin, momentan Nirling. Nirling
ist ein Tool, das
Flaschen und Arbeiten auf Embedded Devices angenehmer
machen soll und
im Prinzip den ganzen
Sack mit, ich muss eine Toolchain aufsetzen
und zu es rot setzen und so weiter und sofort an der Stelle
rausnehmen möchte,
dann möchte ich gerne einen Shoutout zum
Tide-Projekt machen.
Tide ist ein
Web-Framework in Rust,
das ich sehr, sehr angenehm und sehr
accessible finde. Die arbeiten gerade
an einer sehr guten Doku und
das kann ich allen sehr empfehlen.
Und der letzte Pick, weil Weihnachten
ist und weil es gerade rausgekommen ist,
Ruby 3.
Ja, genau. Ruby 3 ist draußen und ich muss ehrlich sagen, es ist super spannend. Ich grabe mich gerade durch. Es hat einmal ein Thread-Safety-Konzept, das ich spannend finde und worüber alle reden und worüber alle Leute nicht reden, ist, dass das jetzt auch noch einen Async-Scheduler für jeden Thread dabei hat, der auf viel von dem arbeitet, was sie mit Ruby 2 alles eingeführt haben.
und ich find's einen total spannenden Release
und einen richtig, richtig guten Release.
Und da werd ich jetzt auch ein paar Runden drehen mit.
Und hab mal wieder richtig viel Spaß an Rubi.
Das ist ja die Ecke, aus der ich herkomme,
bevor ich angefangen habe mit Rust.
Florian wird zurückwechseln.
Nee, aber ich bin immer noch gespannt.
Leute reden immer über Rubi schlecht.
Und dann kommen die mit so einem Release um die Ecke,
den ich wirklich, wirklich spannend finde.
sie die Sprache nochmal sehr neu interpretieren.
Ich liebe Ruby. Ich habe auch,
bevor ich zu Rust gewechselt bin,
vornehmlich Ruby gemacht.
Das ist eine Right of Pathage, oder?
Für viele Rustations, die immer depicten.
Na, bei mir ist
JavaScript und C.
Ganz wenig PHP.
Das liegt so ein bisschen
daran, dass eine ganze Menge
dass wir
in der Community sehr stark
Community-Leute abgezogen haben.
Das stimmt, auf jeden Fall.
Wir haben die Redner geklaut.
Wie immer könnte man über die PIX
noch über jeden Einzelne
eine komplette Sendung machen.
An dieser Stelle würde ich einfach
mich bei unseren Gästen bedanken
für eine absolut bombastische Sendung.
Das war großartig viel geiler,
als ich es mir hätte vorstellen können.
Es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Vielen Dank an Jan-Erik,
der total spontan zugesagt hat,
weil ich leider viel zu lange
vor mir hergeschoben habe,
ihn endlich einzuladen.
vielen lieben Dank Stefan, dass du
trotz Fahrradunfall
an dieser Sendung teilgenommen hast
reden kann man auch mit Schlinge
aber es geht, ich lebe noch
ich kann noch tippen
solange du nur vor dem Computer sitzen musst
ist es okay
und vor allem vielen, vielen lieben Dank an Florian
dass du dieses Thema vorgeschlagen hast
die war super cool, weil es hat sehr viel
Spaß gemacht mit euch, das ist fast mehr
Congress Feeling in der Folge als die letzten zwei Tage
zusammen
Jetzt nur noch sechs Stunden wach bleiben,
dann hast du alles zusammen.
Genau.
Das stimmt.
Das, was uns jetzt hier fehlt,
im Vergleich zum letzten Kongress,
ist das Live-Publikum,
was die Leute sind,
die als nächstes auf diese Stühle wollen,
um die nächste Sendung hier aufzunehmen.
Aber dafür haben wir nicht so viel Zeitdruck gehabt.
Wir können den lila Teppich abgeben,
auf dem wir gerade stehen,
hier im Zeugespiel.
Das stimmt.
Okay.
Da werde ich auch noch eine Runde mit rumspielen.
Sehr gerne.
Sollen wir den verlinken?
Den Source-Code zu dem...
Ja, alle Links, schmeißt es ins Pad.
Ich werde das dann nochmal ein bisschen sortieren.
Also für alle die Links,
alle die Themen, die wir besprochen haben in dieser Folge,
schaut in die Show Notes. Wir haben hoffentlich
alles verlinkt. Wenn wir Sachen noch nicht verlinkt haben,
dann haben wir es wahrscheinlich einfach vergessen, weil es zu viel ist.
Und dann schreibt uns bitte einfach direkt
auf Twitter an. Auch die Kontakte,
ich würde sagen, vornehmlich Twitter-Handles
unserer Gäste heute,
packe ich alles in die Show Notes.
Und an der Stelle, vielen lieben,
bleibt, dass ihr dabei wart.
Der nächste Podcast in eurem Podcatcher beginnt in,
Kirjan?
Drei.
Zwo.
Eins.